30 seconds
[Music]
I know this life meant for me yeah why
would you plan on Goliath when we got
fed David now you came in giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we get no value to haters
[Music]
okay we are on uh home team today sauce
Vinnie we got Tom in the house Biz doc
as well as uh Rob AKA Malik in the house
as well okay home team a lot of topics
we haven't had a chance to talk issues
all week long your suit looks amazing
but the pants look sharper thank you the
pants they're not pants they were
painted on you're not wearing anything
under them this is weird like oh that's
not a zipper very very impressive this
will be the first time any of our uh uh
experts have done a podcast that's a
good thing about camera angles is
Vinnie's actually wearing briefs right
now okay and today's podcast is
sponsored by I think who was it yours is
Haynes or who are you going I love it
the big the packing one I'm still
wearing brand new ones gentlemen Calvin
Klein just so okay we got a lot to talk
about here's what happened by the way
man every time this guy gets on TV he
scares the crap out of people Jerome
Powell it's out there and there's a
video of himself and Senator Kennedy
going back and forth we'll talk about it
Wall Street Journal fed explorers faster
rate increases boom what happens Dow
NASDAQ down one and a half percent you
got the smps down one and a half percent
you got everybody down one and a half
percent pretty much yesterday after this
announcement was made I don't know if
you heard what ft FTC is doing they have
demanded the Twitter turned over
internal communication related to owner
musk as well as the uh detailed
information about layoffs documents
viewed by The Wall Street Journal I
wonder why the FTC is now investigating
weird Elon Musk there's a guy that said
this year is going to be called the year
of Investigation there's more
investigations going on U.S China having
more problems we'll talk about that uh
Tucker January 6th I think what is
trending right now on Twitter if I'm not
mistaking what is trending on Twitter
right now is Tucker Carlson is a liar uh
we'll talk about whether uh the the
folks getting that hashtag to be
trending is or right or wrong
five takeaways New York Times from Ron
desantis's book you got Vivek ramaswan
who was just on the podcast six or seven
weeks ago rips Trump vows to banish FBI
and 10 fed agencies that'd be an
interesting we'll talk about AOC and uh
Kevin O'Leary went at it I think Kevin
all really I mean he had some uh whether
you like what happened with FTX or not
his thoughts on what AOC has done
calling her the top job killer in
America was powerful there's some things
Jamie dimon said I don't know if you saw
what Jamie Diamond said about a couple
different states in America they may
want to pay attention he's a fan of
where they're investing couple States
it's very important to know Tick Tock is
limiting teams to 60 Minutes of screen
time a day but and there's a big butt oh
yeah there is Twitter Revenue took a big
kid and iPhones are making a plant in
Indiana 700 million dollars we'll talk
about that financial times at an article
who to fire how the biggest companies
plan Mass layoffs we'll definitely talk
about Powell we'll talk about the car
dead power up as more Americans struggle
to make payments Hannity gives interview
to Ron DeSantis before Trump and half of
America lost their minds how could you
do that hey Bill is being pitched on
four day work week which is being
reintroduced in the house as idea gains
speed uh by the way I did some digging
on this one it'd be interesting to see
if you can guess what country without
Googling this what country works the
least amount of hours per week and what
that number is we'll talk about that
Mansion had some things to say to Biden
you can't just tax your way out of debt
we got some rules on China Investments
and xnbc Doctor gets no jail time after
asking a girl nine-year-old for nudes
near these storms pretty wild when you
hear these stores okay so let's go into
the first story which is people want to
know what is going on just two days ago
Wall Street Journal said the fact that
you know mortgage applications in the
month of February were the lowest in 28
years a lot of people were concerned
30-year fix was at 6.65 if your credit
is Flawless a lot of people are paying
seven and a half points right now had a
call yesterday with a guy that runs a
mortgage company not available
yet that the recent reports shown
inflation remains stubborn and that the
job market remains resilient are likely
to shake shown inflation uh uh up the
policy trajectory for American central
banks Powell suggested that the peak
rate projection of five to five and a
quarter for interest rates would need to
be adjusted by more than that without
specifying how much more Tom how bad is
this going to get
um we said it was happening and it's
here right now just for everybody's
reference
um the federal rate is
four seven five four point five it's in
a quarter point span the way they do it
and what that means that's what banks
borrow the money from and then they turn
that into car loans mortgages and things
like that at the beginning of the year
Pat people thought that the rate
increases were going to stop probably
around mayor June and then start getting
some reductions yep so that car loans
would be more affordable as we hit back
to school
mortgages may be more affordable fourth
quarter third quarter that's what people
thought that this first half of Tale of
Two Cities first half of 23 kind of
tough second half of 23. things getting
better a little bit of sunshine well
economic data came out and it it looks
bad it looks like inflation is really
hot and not being tamed in the last
podcast we talked about Larry Summers
said hey the fed's really behind the
curve here they got to make a move and
guess what Jerome Powell yesterday said
we're going to be raising rates
he won't say how much but everybody is
basically and the market has reacted
everybody saw the market down that it's
going to be a half a point in about a
week on March 22nd what they're worried
about is that it'll also be a half a
point on May 3rd and then a quarter
point in June a quarter point in July so
that is a point and a half that would
take it not to the 5.5 remember
everybody's thinking 5.5 but all the way
to six maybe six and a quarter and so
with those rates up mortgages uh just
hit a wall we covered in the last
podcast a 28-year low and the number of
mortgages per week 28 years
phenomenal and so it basically
translates to Carl car loan percentages
interest rates are not going down
anytime soon probably not until fourth
quarter the way this is looking because
I want to show you this I want to show
you this if you can play this clip with
Jerome Powell yesterday him and Senator
Kennedy going back and forth and uh
what's important about this it's three
minutes and 45 seconds I asked Elon if
he can speed up the stuff on Twitter I
don't think they have it yet to do the
playback speed I think you just have to
play it at the speed that they have but
everybody has to watch this exchange
watch this typically when you see these
things what do you think about the guy's
not going to admit to anything he's
going to play [__] he's going to
play dumb he's going to play this watch
what Powell does he does some Stonewall
he just tells you yep that's what's
going to happen that's what's going to
happen there is zero fluffle answers
here he straight up gives it to you play
the clip watch this you're raising
interest rights you're raising interest
rates to slow the economy are you not
yes to cool the economy off
um and one of the ways you measure your
success other than
fluctuation and gross domestic product
is the unemployment rate
is it not yes one of the measures okay
so when a fact this I'm not being
critical
when you're slowing the economy you're
trying to put people out of work that's
your job is it not
really we're trying to we're trying to
restore price stability no you're trying
you're trying to raise it's not wages
you're trying to raise the unemployment
rate
that me I know you don't like the phrase
so let me strike it you're trying to
raise the unemployment rate are you not
no we're not trying to raise you we're
trying to realign supply and demand
which could happen through a bunch of
channels like for example uh you know
just job openings we put it another way
okay
The Economist did a did a wonderful
study
they looked at at 10 disinflationary
periods in America going all the way
back to the 1950s disinflation is what
you're trying to do it's a slowing in
the rate of inflation
am I right yes in other words prices
don't go down they just don't go up as
fast
deflation is when prices actually go
down you're trying to achieve
disinflation are you not yes we are okay
based on history in the 10 times
that we got inflation down disinflation
since the 1950s
in order to reduce inflation by two
percent
unemployment had to go up 3.6 percent
now that's history is it not
I don't have the numbers in front of me
but yes the standard has been that there
are five recessions and downturns one
fed has tried watches the current
inflation rate 6.4 percent in the
current unemployment rate is 3.4 percent
now if history is right I'm not asking
you to to to again blame anybody but if
history is Right unless you get some
help
in order to get inflation down from 6.4
percent
to let's say 4.4 percent and the
unemployment rate is going to have to
rise to seven percent based on history
that's what the record would say okay
and to get inflation down to 2.2 percent
watch this based on history here we go
an immutable fact watch unemployment
would have to go to 10.6 percent
would it not oh no I wouldn't I wouldn't
that's what the record that's what the
history shows yeah yeah I don't think
that kind of a number is is at all I
mean I know you're reluctant to admit it
and you don't want to get in the middle
of a policy uh dispute
but I think it's undeniable
it's undeniable
that the only way we're going to get
this sticky inflation down is to attack
it on the monetary side which you're
doing
and on the fiscal side which means
Congress has got to reduce the rate of
growth of spending and reduce reduce the
rate of growth yeah
yes you do
I get that you don't want to get in the
middle of that fight
but the more we help
on the fiscal side the fewer people
you're going to have to put out of work
isn't that a fact
please answer good work out that way
couldn't work out that would work out
that way yes sir thank you thank you sir
zero hiding anything now here's the
thing
Kennedy is a what he's a republican
right from Louisiana Jerome Powell was
assigned by who Trump trump and he's
still here by who so he is
he he is both unbiased but he knows I
think he's disliked by both sides okay
let me tell you you're saying disliked
or Bible yes
l-i-k-e-d he's disliked by both sides
and let me tell you this is going to
sound weird he's exactly where he needs
to be okay yeah here's here's my opinion
yes you have to not be spending more
money and forcing Congress to not have a
bigger budget yes yes we have to do yes
you have to kind of go through this what
do you want to do delay the time bomb
even more and more and more for other
people what else do you need to do with
this we're gonna go through a season
that's gonna suck I'm talking to this
guy yesterday first question asked how
much money you got saved he says we're
good okay good because you know one of
our Moses yeah you got to always have
your cash in place so you don't have to
make desperate decisions I said just so
you know how long do you think this is
going to last I'm asking this guy was in
a real estate business him and his wife
are on he says Pat
we're not we're not counting 23 as a
year where anything's gonna go our way I
say that's good because that's probably
what's going to end up happening to the
real estate and a mortgage Racing for
the storm right they are and by the way
there are some great Crusaders who are
in the real estate and the mortgage side
that have convinced everybody
everything's going to be fine this
season is coming and and and when
unemployment remember when you ask the
question what should I do and all of a
sudden what number should and I said we
looked at unemployment by States and
remember Nevada was at five percent wow
look at Nevada and it's like no they
went from 23 to 1000 to 5 okay
if this thing goes the way it's going
unemployment hits five six seven he's
saying 10 point something percent listen
when is the last time unemployment hit
10 outside of Kobe outside don't count
covert outside that's ten percent I
think the nice man is in Hospice Care in
Plains Georgia was this is Jimmy Carter
before before I was even born without
winning this seven late seventies I
think it's 79 80. when is the last time
if you just go to history of
unemployment rate that's all you got to
do history of certainly not in my
lifetime ah history of unemployment
ready to go 1982 10.1 the last time I
hit double digits was 1982 10.1 and by
the way do you know the month that uh
Joe Biden became president I think that
month or the following month I did a
video comparing him to Jimmy Carter yeah
those two guys have all we have a case
study of this it's called Jimmy Carter
and we're there yeah yeah I mean
obviously if it gets that extreme
right that's what you're saying if it
gets to 10 percent
okay so if you don't do that then what
is the alternative imagine if Powell
doesn't do so let's say Powell doesn't
know what he's doing right now what
happens the economy overheats inflation
runs amok you know pricing is out of
control he's he's I think Jerome power
is exactly right yeah drone pile is
doing what he's got to do I agree and by
the way you know what I like about the
way he took his position he came you
know what he looked like he looked like
listen guys I don't give a [__] what you
ask yes we're raising thank you yeah you
look like but left right middle we're
raising the raids what do you like yeah
it's almost like that yeah I think what
is it's funny because
Senator John Candy from yeah it seems
like a character of a guy just don't
know what the hell he's talking about
but he actually in essence did know it
just doesn't sound like it yeah but so
he he's uh he's a he's a credible dude
he's been around forever he's the crazy
Senator if he gets past his Accenture
um he is you can't get past the accent
but he was a former treasurer of
Louisiana Senator attorney lawyer he
just happens to sound like he's a wild
bill but what what what no somebody's
saying yeah bang bang what what we also
know is that oh I don't know what just
happened no it'd be it's the equivalent
of a guy trying to come up to bizdoc on
who's been around the block a little bit
but not nowhere near bizdoc's level
and Biz doctor's like okay I'm hearing a
pitch for the billionth time about
raising Capital but how many
conversations do you think Jerome Powell
is an economist extraordinaire this
guy's a senator who kind of knows a
little bit I appreciate the questions
but Jerome Powell is a beast and I think
he's doing a great job and I think he's
really even temper for that yeah even
temperament he's almost like the United
Goodfellas and like oh you can't believe
what's his birthday real quick Jerome
Powell I just this is random February
32nd though no no no you nailed that I'm
buying February 4th all right that's
also my birthday so I'm a big 32nd
but I if you could give a grade to
Jerome Powell not a household name at
this juncture in in the economy right
now what grade do you give him today
I give him a solid a not an A minus not
an A plus just a solid a um yeah I think
he's got a hard job bro I think he's got
a you know what's the hardest job here's
the hardest job so think about it this
way the hardest job is when you're about
to make a decision and your mom and dad
have never ever agreed on anything in
their lives and they're divorced so
whatever your dad agrees on your mom
disagrees whatever your mom thinks it's
a good idea your dad is such a great
analogy you go to your mom and you say
hey Mom here's what I'm thinking about
I'm thinking about
lower in interest rates what do you
think terrible idea did dad tell you to
do that yeah
terrible ideas your father know you came
up here it's the first time ever in 50
years your parents have disagreed on the
same thing and you're confused and you
still think you're making the right
decision that's Jerome Powell
he's in a rough place but listen but
between unemployment and everything you
know the bottom line here and let's
bring it home so everybody can
understand this the economy is in a
pickle you get unemployment you get the
interest rates I mean these shows
100 we're in a pickle so basically you
guys know all the questions I always ask
so I have to wait till 2024 to think
about buying unless there's a shift in
listings in South Florida right pretty
much but is there do you have any graphs
to back up this pickle no but no but you
went through the numbers so where where
is there like a chart that I can see to
understand like I understand the
cheerleader being the economy and Jerome
Powell's headed upstairs again next week
yeah
stairs but do you have a chart you have
something to actually Vinnie I think we
might yeah okay okay do you have the
interest rate very interesting look at
that weird best dog you have the
interest rate chart everybody let's take
a look at this yeah this is called a
pickle chart yes so
so I wonder why yeah on the left hand
side what's going on
January 1st the consensus estimates of
economic people was the pickle on the
left see thinking that it was going to
get up to about 5.4 start to lose a
little steam and then and second half of
the year is going to be looking a little
bit better the revised estimates that
we're hearing now because the economy is
still overheated is the pickle on the
right and unfortunately that is a much
more formidable pickle than the American
economy was expecting got it yep yeah
and that's it and so the point is
heading for a half a percent romp next
week on March 22nd another half Point
fling probably what is that what is the
national average of a pickle interest
rate size uh
I don't know if that's where you're
going with this yeah I'm still sitting
here waiting to see what well go ahead
so collecting notes so a couple quarter
point quickies in June and July and then
the interest rates will start deflating
or that's right and that's when that's
what most people pal you know we'll see
what he needs to see and he kind of runs
out of steam in September we definitely
don't want to run out of steam please
leave the cheerleader because I really
want to buy a townhouse or a house for
the audience we with uh on behalf of uh
the crew we'd like to apologize for you
having to see a couple pickles here just
so you guys know this is nothing uh it's
a pickle
by the way I just had a hamburger today
that Apple made and there was pickles in
it it was great you don't like pickle I
loved it it was great I took the onions
out because there's a few things onion
cigarettes certain things you shouldn't
do in life or around you though did it
just you just smell you touch your hands
anyways hey uh today's sponsor Aura
listen uh if you haven't yet done this
I've been in the insurance industry for
20 plus years everything is about
preparation anticipation in case
something bad happens to you we don't
buy insurance policies because we're
dying tomorrow we don't buy auto
insurance because we're about to get
into car accident you buy because God
forbid if something happens you families
taken care of the same way why you buy
And subscribe to what Aura does to
prevent if somebody decides to go take
advantage of your stolen credit cards
passwords on the dark web any of that
stuff so if you go to Aura or allows you
to check to see how many of your
passwords are being used on the dark web
they're an identity theft protection
company fraud monitoring a VPN password
management and antivirus software all
combined into one easy to use app and
all of this you can get with uh uh with
aura protect you and yourself from
America's fastest growing crime try Aura
free for two weeks and see if any of
your or your family's personal
information has been compromised
start your 14-day trial at aura.com
forward slash pbd once again Aura
aura.com forward slash pbd or.com pbd
when the economy is tough man there's
these fraudsters are out there trying to
get after you 10 times more than usual
this is going to be happening that's a
good point yep okay so uh you know next
thing if we want to get into this four
day work weekly conversation that
they're starting to have
uh a four day work week bill is being
reintroduced in the house as idea gains
speed okay let's see if this is a good
idea or a bad idea by the way the other
day Tom I did a survey okay I did a
survey which by the way Kai and I are
sitting there and we're debating what we
believe the results of the survey are
going to be before I get into this
article let me read you what the survey
was the survey was
the four day work week okay four day
work week is it a good idea is it a bad
idea or you don't care
25 000 people voted for this did you see
this or no time the polls I've not seen
the point okay so 25 000 people voted
for this on Twitter the four day work
week what would you say I think you just
saw it so I don't know I didn't actually
I didn't see it which one you think
people voted for the most from the least
to the highest don't show it yet right
I've just texted it to you let me ask
the question again what are your
thoughts on four day work weeks don't
care
bad idea good idea what got the most
votes
what got the least votes Tom I would
assume if we're talking 410 so I work 10
hours four days there's my 40 hours I
would assume good idea probably gets the
most and people would want like a
three-day weekend
so you're saying most people voted for
good idea what do you say I'm the same
as if I think people just right off the
rip knowing that they're going to have
Friday off as well I say they're going
to say that's the most one yeah so it's
a good idea bad idea and don't care and
don't care oh everybody cares I'm
assuming okay yeah uh I I agree people
want this people so okay so watch this
if you want to pull up the poll this is
what the poll results was
good idea 55 said it's a good idea half
55 so let me read this entire article I
got some thoughts on this and I want to
hear yours I can't believe it there's 25
percent of them that don't care it's
your [__] life here buddy I don't
know five days seven days democratically
whatever I don't give a [__] Democratic
Democratic representative mark takano
from California plans to reintroduce a
bill that will shorten the standard work
week Tom it's not what you said it's not
for 10 hour work days it's going from 40
hours to 32 hours a week okay
the proposal would improve the quality
of life workers meeting the demand for
more uh trunctuate trunk truncated
truncated work week that allows room to
live pay play enjoy life more outside of
work to kind of build has been endorsed
by Major labor unions like AFL-CIO Union
Food and Commercial Workers and service
employees International Union as well as
the Congressional Progressive caucus uh
is made up of 100 members of Congress
the proposal has historical precedent
with labor union Union successfully
pressuring lawmakers to shorten the work
to eight hours of four days a week
instead of five go ahead Tom I'll go to
you can you read the last sentence of
that paragraph in the middle there
that's important Pat ours worked past
that period unless otherwise specified
would be subject to higher compensation
there we go okay so tell us about it Tom
this takano the Democrat from California
he is trying to move the overtime line
and he's doing it on a populist thing
about a four day work week well look let
me talk about two things in California
four tens it's called is very common in
the entertainment industry editors Do It
um in Southern California those
Motion Picture companies still having
editors Southern California Universal's
got them all in Orlando Florida
and so a 410 means you work 10 hours
four days shooting schedules for
Entertainment also very common 410 so
that's your 40 hours what this guy is
doing is saying the standard work week
would be 32 hours and hours work past
that period subject to higher
compensation
code word overtime he this is giving
basically a rate he's trying to give a
raise to workers by changing moving the
line on the 40-hour work week so there's
a lot can be said about a four day work
week especially if I commute long way
hey if I'm commuting a long way away
maybe I want to work four tens that's
not so bad that would be eight to seven
with a one hour lunch in there you know
maybe you want to do that if I'm an
editor and I just sit there cranking
away or doing something like that and
then I take an extra day on my weekend
but I've worked my 40 hours this guy's
trying to
move a burden onto employer's path and
move the overtime Adam what do you think
about it I actually have very strong
feelings about this I think you know
it's almost laughable the the work-life
balance I gotta have a work-life balance
but this is very important for workers
here's my suggestion I love like when
doctors nurses firefighters where they
like work their [__] ass off and then
they get to take like three days off
four days off and I think we all know
that the average worker just kind of
comes it works they do their thing they
do their thing whatever I don't know
kind of have a gig it's been a while
since Pat has even thought about that so
he always laughs but the average man
does these days he was once that guy but
because like for me timers now for me
I'm working 24 7. I'm never like not I'm
like don't call me I'm not working yeah
here's my suggestion though
um if you're gonna work four days a week
I wouldn't go from 40 hours to 32 hours
I would go from 40 hours to 45 hours I
would that word truncated that that we
were discussing I would Mash in four
days of [__] crushing it for your
company give give someone the option to
do that I think because the company is
going to be open on Friday some
companies are open seven days a week
give the employee the option of what
they want to do hey you can do your
standard five day 40 hour week if you
want to work four days you're actually
going to work more hours not less
and let them pick I think if the
sentiment of this poll is any indicator
of what's going on people actually kind
of agree with this listen yeah all right
let's see I mean I have some thoughts
but I want to hear you guys first go
ahead well I'm just saying I'm for
somebody like me Pat working at
valuetainment I have no family here you
guys are my friends I'm coming in Monday
through Friday four days get the hell
out of here people are gonna go nuts in
those four days I like it Monday through
Friday keep it old school then you know
then those people are gonna start
complaining about those four days I'm
like can you believe they made us Adams
Adam made us do 45 hours yeah that
Tyrant and then that [__] that problem
when you're at work you have an idea I
want to offer one more thing I got so
many thoughts
this isn't Last Word this is something
to happen here we go how many time zones
in the United States three outside of
Hawaii for the court right so if you
need people and you want to say hey we
want to cover nine to five in all time
zones so if you need something from us
you can call our home office you can get
customer service four times those
eastern central Mountain Pacific then
hawaii five right no no no the
continental US is just three three you
have to cover three hours
because it's three hours between here
and L.A keep going thank you and so what
you do is you is you ask people it says
would you like to work
this so that you can cover these hours
so we can cover our customers and you
provide we provided a vision to them hey
we're just trying to cover our customers
who have been nine to five in any time
zone they can get a hold of us we can
answer questions and help them okay so
there's reasons to do it not this guy
can I give my thoughts here's my
thoughts let me let me let me share some
of my thoughts here so number one okay
for this side a whole concept we have to
first thing we have to do is we have to
define success what is success okay
let's define success is Success people
having more time on their hands to chill
out and do nothing is that what success
is or is Success building companies that
creates jobs that the government doesn't
have to come and build people out the
moment we define success every single
decision is predicated based on the
definition of success the moment we do
that okay so if we go with the first one
and we say success is giving people more
time on their hands no problem let's
investigate that when you and I were
kids okay I have four kids you when I
were kids when we were kids what's the
secret sauce we've always heard parents
did to prevent kids from doing stupid
[__] what did what did parents do how do
you keep your kids away from making dumb
decisions do you give them activities
after school such as what such as
reading a book you monitor their
homework
or playing they're playing basketball in
the driveway yeah they're friends you
know what they're doing but they're
active so let me ask you this what
happened when you and I as kids had too
much time on our hands honestly I lit
fires with magnifying glasses what do we
do and I'm being very serious with you
what did we do when we had too much
fires my brother and I and I was playing
more sports but you I okay for certain
kids they will get into more trouble no
no not for certain kids they will get in
trouble if you have more time on your
hands you having more time on your hands
you're going to get in trouble you are
going to do what you know drugs alcohol
ganks you know porn more video stupidity
the moment you have more time on your
hands fine okay so watch this a lady
who's a liberal from UCLA University
goson does a study to see how much free
time
produces good things with people and you
know what number she figured out I'll
read it to you here because we have to
do the research on this based on a
project that we're working on here's
what she came up with this is a lady
named a modular homes they did a
research and a survey on 21 000
different people and that's the number
they found out okay they wanted to find
out at what point is your mental health
taken a shot the study was specifically
done when covet happened everybody's
being home like we got to figure this
part out how much free time is good how
much free time is bad here's what you
realize people need two hours of free
time why to be able to go out there and
do their you know your chores pay the
bills go get the haircut go do the
shopping all this other stuff if it's
less than two hours of free time a day
they have Stress and Anxiety it's not
good for them so you got an hour and a
half lunch and you got an hour nine
that's two and a half hours she said the
moment it went to five hours of free
time Stress and Anxiety went up why
because you started realizing am I not
valued am I not important can you not
use me to do productive things people
want to be valued if they're not being
used to be valued they see themselves as
I'm worthless I don't feel that good I
become bitter I have an attitude now
let's continue a little bit more with
this topic here on four day work week
okay so if we define success of
producing companies that did very well
the country in the world that they work
the least amount of hours a week you
know what country it is Italy it's
Netherlands you know how many hours a
week it's number one on the list 29
hours a week is what they work 29 hours
a week so we went through the bottom 10
smoking a lot of weed there in Amsterdam
no question about it again if we define
success as production that the world
benefits from your Innovation if that is
the definition of success you are not
going to do it at a 29 hour uh at a what
do you call it work week I agree at a yo
right there they're doing 27 and a half
hours the study I saw was 29 it's gone
down to 27 and a half hours Netherlands
number one on the list
keep going keep going Norway
he's Scandinavians
socialists keep going there they go
Europe
keep going
Switzerland keep going
to keep going one watch a year all
Europe but what the hell is going on
here's the problem watch this here
here's the question yeah we looked at
what companies they have invented that
has come out of their countries that
we've benefited from we have benefited
from the reason why Europe can work as
little as they do is because we and to
innovate they take advantage of we fund
NATO they sit around and don't do [__]
Europe is a socialist Nation not a
nation what do you want to call it
Nations
Europe Union they are they are
socialists because we allow them to
become socialists okay let me go to the
next one here some Industries where they
work with works not all Industries it
does there's another one it depends on
the face of a company if a company has
been around for 100 years it's 100
billion dollar company they don't give a
[__] if you're a four-day work week
they're already working for the workload
there's so many Executives I remember
one insurance company there was a guy
that was making a fat salary with this
big ass insurance company all of us know
about you could never get a hold of them
you could never do anything with them
never called you back never did anything
work from home is making a half a
million years not doing [__] one day we
had a meeting I think you were part of
that meeting do you remember what
happened in that meeting very heated
meeting you know which one I'm talking
about where I said why the hell are you
giving me a rep like this that doesn't
do [__] I said let me tell you doesn't
call me back doesn't do the guy got
fired okay he had to leave and he come
and says what I have to do I can't
nobody can ever get a hold of you
nothing you're not supporting us there
are a lot of major companies you can do
the four-day work week maybe even
mid-size you there's no way in the world
you can do four day work week in a
startup no way good luck to you how the
hell are you gonna do four day work not
gonna start up you're not gonna do it so
here's the point I love it
if they convince people to voluntarily
go to a four-day work week you know why
because the people that are going to
voluntarily do six day work weeks game
over totally fine all the four-day
people go to the four day companies all
the five six day people that want to go
take over the world and make this and do
something impactful come to us we're
okay with that the level of consequences
on a four day work week is so massive
that all people are thinking about is
what is the next thing I can pitch for
people to vote for me so I can get
reelected and get another eight years of
salary and whatever else I need to be
doing it's a box of [__] but it's
very Marketing in fact was one of the
main reasons for all this situation all
this talk yeah because people are like
bro I'm doing everything from home if I
do come in now I want to be here less
than I would have been before so let me
stay home for one more day am I am I am
I right knows what state was that Media
company in that I was running when I had
to do all this California oh Cali oh and
did what is that group in Sacramento EDD
yeah they were just a pain yeah so you
get regulated into this these things
that I did I did to accommodate to get
the job done to get customer service but
you know what my fantasy football team
for my for my employees Pat you're
absolutely right it's the people that
were there six days that was my fantasy
team yeah guess what though man this
listen I the only thing that concerns me
if it is mandatory if it's going to be
volunteer do it I say I'll vote for it
yeah I'll vote for it if you want to do
it volunteer if it's volunteer if it's
mandatory it's problematic by the way
let me add another thing to another wrap
and I'll come to you early retirement
good thing or a bad thing
well 55 years old or 62 years old or 60
is it a good thing or a bad thing no I
do not like that let me read this to you
earlier early retirement before the age
of six I'm reading it to you from my
computer yeah early retirement before
the age of 62 has been associated with
higher mortality rate risk in some
instances a study of Shell Oil Company
watch this a study of Shell Oil company
found those who retire at 55. listen to
this Tom Tom listen to this Tom a study
of shell employees found that those who
retire at 55 lived to be 65 die 37
sooner than those who retired 65.
they're not doing anything they're just
stagnant go sitting retired 55 10 years
before 65 they died 37 sooner and in
general people retire at 55 or 89 more
likely to die within 10 years that's
those that retire at 55 or 89 percent
more likely to die in within 10 years
than those who retired 65. so 48 work
week is a form of retirement as well
that's exactly what I said a reason I
held up those nine figures right there
Pat where you were talking is because
I've heard after age 58 and this is what
this is saying retire whenever you want
you've not you've got nine years Wow
that's scary that's crazy that's what
it's saying retire when you want after 8
58 or later you have nine years I
thought why would you what so why how
would you correlate that to what so are
you saying because they're just sitting
around they're not they're not active
they're not doing anything bro I want to
feel important we we are put here to
feel important you ever see these
protesters that go out there and scream
and yeah yeah you're like what the heck
that is a form of attention growth that
we link important yeah okay we
teach our kids how to feel important if
the way they get our attention every
time they get in trouble they're always
going to get in trouble because that's
how they get your love yeah it's it's
the way we teach importance when you're
sitting around you got nothing you're
doing anything for you're not making an
impact you feel useless what the hell am
I living for maybe I'm no longer needed
you're you're right I'm no longer
checking out yeah I'm checking out yeah
wow so if I could add to that um
absolutely right the number one thing
that I think everyone is looking for
everyone that's listening to this right
now is having meaning and purpose to
their life no doubt that's like above
work above starting a business
everyone's searching for that uh my
whole thing was I went from being sort
of
when I was young not really trying to
work jack of all trades nightclubs
having fun here and there wasn't
concerned about money the exact opposite
of building a business and then I went
all in into the finance world and I'm
working a ridiculous amount working like
burning the midnight hour making cold
calls just for like 10 years grinding
and then I look back and I'm like holy
[__] I've got money in the bank I've got
hundreds of thousands I'm a millionaire
this is crazy and what did I do at that
point I took the pedal off the metal and
I went back I started doing a four day
work week I said Fridays you can go [__]
yourself like don't call me I'm not
answering the phone I was living in
South Beach vacation time money in the
bank I'm not worried I'm chilling but
that only lasts for so long so at some
point I said all right I'm going to
Mykonos I'm going to San Tropez I'm
going to St Barts I'm dating a girl she
lives in Europe or London I'm having a
great time travel travel the girl and I
don't work out what happens
I'm like all right I want to do
something I'm sick of the travel I've
done it I ask everybody's like how often
do you want to travel before it's like I
want to travel the world it's like all
right after you do that what are you
gonna do the rest of your life there's
another world so then what I realize is
now is that like having meaning and
purpose in your life I started a little
Instagram show that Pat and I were like
this is years ago he's like dude start
start doing stuff
I was like oh I like this and now I'm
doing two jobs working my ass off so
that Friday that I replaced now became
every Friday Saturday Sunday I'm working
on a side hustle because I I wanted to
have meaning and purpose in my life I
always say that my job is what I do it's
not who I am there's a big difference a
big disconnect this is a little bit more
who I am so money gives you options
right so what happens is as I'm doing my
job and I'm starting interviewing all
these wealthy people nalba heckerling
Financial conferences I started asking
the really really rich people the
Millionaires and the billionaires and I
said all right like after you get the
millions of billions like what do you do
do you just retire they're like retire
yeah like I'm gonna do this forever like
because to Pat's credit
you want to have meaning and purpose in
your life it's not just about the money
and what I found out was that these
really wealthy people didn't just retire
and do nothing what did they do there's
three major things they travel they
pursue a passion starting a podcast
whatever right
or they give away their money and they
donate their money why because they want
to leave a legacy so there's different
phases I I just kind of walked you
through three phases at one phase of
just like party guy not worried about
[__] you know I don't care about money
to like holy [__] money's pretty
important let me do that I made money
let me take my pedal off the metal and
then you kind of get re-engaged with the
next phase of your career you're big on
chapters in your life Pat right zero to
twenty don't [__] it up you mean you can
you can kind of say what those things
are in there yeah but by the way Adam
you you're making a very good point
because you've experienced it right you
didn't have to do it and when you live
live like that by the way years go by so
quickly you ain't doing [__] all the
time four years went by yep not four
years one but waste of a life when you
do that for too long of a time but uh by
the way just to wrap this thing up I'll
just give you more logic side to this
what happens if a person's working five
days they go to four weeks four days
that's one on five is what twenty
percent right if a company loses 20 of
Labor they have to hire 20 of Labor for
the same amount okay so if they go have
to make up the other 20 of hours that
they're gonna need the labor what
happens then then I have to raise my
prices by 20 a five dollar broker
becomes six bucks okay a fifty thousand
dollar car has to become 60 Grand okay I
just have to do it because I gotta make
up that additional twenty percent that I
gotta go higher labor for people that
sell this from the manipulative way that
unions sell this thinking they're doing
the right thing they have no they don't
care about the person that's sitting
there what is going to happen on the
other end you think they care if price
is going to go up on 20 they're just
happy they're getting reelected doesn't
affect them that much yeah and by the
way I'm gonna send you this thing take a
look at this year states that uh
population change in 2022 show this
chart if you can rob uh on what happened
I'm sending it to your MacBook Pro I
don't know if you're seeing it or I'll
send it to your phone and the computer
if you're seeing it pull it up check
this out and while they're looking it up
remember Union skip get dues based on
low percent based on what you earn
they'd love you to make more overtime
and they'd love to have more people
making less they make more that way one
hundred percent so guess what if you can
show this chart guys watch this here not
the pickle chart please rob no we've had
enough pickles for today watch this here
look at this make it big so we can see
it you know what that is that's the
states that lost people and states that
gain people yeah California keep doing
stupid things keep doing it people are
people that are leaving you are the
people we want in Florida wow that's a
great chart the people that are leaving
you they're coming to States like ours
keep doing four day work week [__]
Union stuff driving the entrepreneur out
just like you keep losing people like
musk Rogan stick you know big job
creators keep leaving your first time
net you know of your population going
lower since 1851 you keep doing stuff
like that look at the North By the way
look on the other side look up
Pennsylvania look at New York look at
look at what they're going through look
at Illinois look at all those guys no
problem Oregon keep doing it Texas
winning Florida winning Arizona winning
Utah winning South Carolina winning
North Carolina winning
this is I would break this down to
losing people yeah I was going to say
break this down into
80 20 rule like 80 percent of the map
where people are getting the hell out of
are the over regulated highly liberal
blue States typically right they're
getting the hell out of California or
they're getting the hell out of Oregon
they're getting hell out of New York
right Illinois all that you know but uh
so absolutely right they're moving to
Florida Texas no doubt but the flip side
is the 20 percent
what the hell is going on in Louisiana
Mississippi West Virginia I mean nobody
wants any part of that you're nobody's
moving to these states very just just a
little food for thought nobody wants to
be part of a shitty State and so what
kind of rules are going on in those
states that are driving out their people
that's what I'm wondering we know what's
driving out people from liberal states
to more conservative States we know that
you know you know I'll tell you Adam
I'll tell you this give me the shittiest
State okay let me run it for 20 years
hear me out whatever you call as a
shitty State any one of these states let
us run it for 20 years it will be the
greatest state in America will attract
the best talent to come to our small
little state that we have I don't care
how big of a state that is listen bad
policies have consequences bad ideas
have consequences leadership good ideas
attracts people who go there because one
thing happens to create Gators doers and
creators are interested in one thing
they want to feel safe
they want to go to a state that they
feel safe trust me they can sit there
and say well I have to deal with
mosquitoes I have to deal with lizards I
have to deal with rabbits I have to deal
with this I have to deal with hurricane
I have to deal with tornado I have to
deal with I don't give you any crisis
you got in any state
free thinkers endures want to go to a
place that they're going to feel safe
that their ideas are not going to be
ripped apart and they're going to be
treated like [__] like California is
treating them no doubt period Scream by
the way when people say well why is
California the top economy in the world
top economy in the in in America it's
the number four number five economy in
the world if it was a country because of
policies that came out 50 years ago not
right now the policy that came out 30
years ago not right now they're so into
deep now that those companies cannot
leave anymore you think you think if you
think if uh Bezos had to do it all over
again you think he would have gone to
Seattle what do you think no but it's
too late you kind of are stuck now
you're in Seattle across the street from
Microsoft yeah some of these things
happen New York and Wall Street he's
building headquarter two in Virginia
after ao's yeah just looking at this
real quick if we had to as a team with
you as the leader take over one of these
states
no take it over I mean besides us where
would you where would you go on there
anywhere I don't
I don't care where you put it we'll get
the best people to come I believe it I
don't care where you put New Mexico you
are you about to make an announcement is
an announcement happening I just bought
New Mexico interests Pat people are
asking no no everyone wants to know no
no no no no no don't don't create rumors
I'm just saying like all I'm saying is
certain policies are gonna attract those
people I'd be go I would be in
California for a month straight in a
freaking RV driving up and down up and
down up and down up and down hey this is
Patrick David from the state of XYZ
we're here to talk to those of you that
are actually working yeah that are
feeling like you're paying too much
taxes we got a solution for you come to
our state come on now let me explain to
you what we're doing well no no no are
you sick and tired of the Union that's
what we'd be doing we would literally be
sitting there recruiting people don't
worry get on the bus we'll drive down to
our state and get on together here
that's what we'll be doing I love it and
we'd have a freaking Time Of Our Lives
but we're building a media company it's
a whole different story so come on down
to value
on a serious note if you want to work in
media and you want to work in South
Florida you should go check us out
because we've got opportunities for
people that want to hustle thank you end
of plug and by the way it's not even in
the plug where we interviewed our ninth
editor-in-chief the people that are
calling us are from some of the biggest
media companies in America pretty
impressive people that are coming in
with the resumes that are some of the
names you know we're hiring we just
hired a CFO we're hiring a general
manager to run the entire uh what do you
call it our consulting firm is blowing
up yeah we need technology folks we need
ctOS we need CEOs by the way qualified
we're not talking about let me just send
a resume because I want to be part of
the team we need folks who are maybe
retired but you had a couple exes for 50
million 100 million that you have a lot
of value to bring to others we want
experts because we can sell your time as
a consultant there's a lot of different
things we're looking for right now if
you do have a resume email at Robert
valuetainment once again Robert at the
entertainment.com
okay all right next uh can you play that
clip Jamie dimon was asked this question
I'm gonna read this article and I don't
want to play this clip by the way I'm
just playing Harriet who's this Pat Rob
was that you
folks I hear Pat I hear I think it's
every time you open it up it comes up so
I don't know what the it's a replay
I hear people how are you okay okay so
let's take a look at this so JP Morgan
is growing in Florida and Texas States
like uh states that like business
Diamond says uh watch just play this
clip let him say what he's saying about
these different states I think you have
the clip somewhere yeah that's the one
right there if we can play that
you got it right
is it just refresh it click on it to
refresh
if there we go there we go
tell me we don't have to watch it there
you go yeah audio
wrap
in Florida it's like the states that
like business dinos watch just play this
clip let him say what he's saying about
these different states I think I hear
the audio on the other Rob one of your
windows is open yeah that one close it
close that YouTube anything that's
YouTube close it okay let me start it
from the beginning hang on let me start
we love hearing your voice Pat I don't
know soothing JP Morgan is growing in
Florida and Texas States like states
that like business Diamond says he says
the following about recession and uh
some people that were not part of these
two states were not happy play this clip
what are you worried about great to be
here by the way so thank you uh the
thing I worry the most about it if you
go it's Ukraine it's oil gas so the
leadership of the world and you know our
relation with China I mean that that is
much more serious than the economic
vibrations we all have to deal with on a
day-to-day basis
I feel like it's so loud I don't know
what just happened with that clip if you
can because it's live until like Jamie
Diamond yelling at that no he wasn't
this by the way all the audio rooms
there is a there's a 30 second clip of
him saying that you you have the longer
one there's a short of him saying that
that he's talking about it while you're
looking for that I'll just read the
article here uh he explains the JPMorgan
Chase is expanding in Florida opening
branches we can hear your typing opening
branches in a state that's seen an
increased influx of Wall Street firm
since the pandemic we love Florida we're
grown in Florida left and right Jamie
Diamond says in an interview in Miami
it's part of a broader move that's seen
firms like Ken Griffin Citadel move
headquarters from Chicago to Miami last
year as well as Arc investment
Management's Kathy Wood relocate to St
Petersburg Florida Florida and Texas are
states that like business they uh uh
they want you to come stay they want you
to come we now have more employees in
Texas than in New York state it
shouldn't have been that way but Texas
loves you being there okay Texas loves
you being there how long is that this is
57 seconds it's pretty much what he's
saying it's the same thing I just read
play the clips or some audience can see
this poor countries and it's rolling
trade relations between America China
and the rest of the world so this is a
probably the most serious geopolitical
thing no it's playing the other one it's
just it's I don't know what's going on
your computer's out of whack right now
yeah it's not playing well don't worry
about it what are your thoughts about
what Jamie's talking about Florida and
Texas Jamie is saying out loud what
everybody's been watching for the last
10 years uh that people are moving here
and now what Jamie is saying he is
here's what he's doing he's speaking in
code he's also speaking to the governor
of New York
you want me you want me to stay here you
need to start playing live so there's a
little you know what I mean Pat when you
say something to somebody and you leave
somebody out the person that's left out
gets the message but he's also stating
the obvious saying hey these states want
us to be here the climate's good that
things are good for business and it
shouldn't have to be that way but Texas
loves you being there with the emphasis
on the loves you being there they feel
welcome and he says and we're growing in
Florida yeah so it's where he's getting
growth so it's uh I guess I guess I mean
I understand well and I'll show up
that's it so treat me well and I'll show
I'll say one thing about Florida being
born and raised in Miami I remember in
the 80s and 90s where I was like the
weird cousin that lived in Miami now
it's not so weird now I'm like it's cool
to live in Florida but it's it's it's
kind of like Bittersweet to that our
little secret that our cat is out the
bag here in Florida a guy like Pat
should have never lived in Florida he
should have been in California because
that's where his family's from but at
some point you're gonna push someone out
who says like if I just do this and this
and this we've done this all the time at
some point a guy like Pat is going to
leave freaking California I like a guy
like Ken Griffin is going to leave New
York he saw that he was the number one
hedge fund manager in the world in the
world by the way made 44 billion dollars
what's the number that he made something
ridiculous four and a half but it's from
himself some ridiculous I think he left
Chicago by the way okay sorry but it I
get it yeah but all these guys you know
are basically moving to Florida but what
what you what the leadership in Florida
that we've seen whether it's DeSantis
whether it's mayor Suarez down in Miami
hedge funds are coming big techs coming
the crypto world has moved here it's
it's it's a very good climate to be in
literally and figuratively uh for
business and for lifestyle and I think
the cat's out the bag of what's going on
in South Florida and Florida overall I I
think that there's enough cats I think
there's a complete different message
we're missing on what Jamie Diamond is
saying what uh Jamie Diamond is in Miami
if Jamie's in Miami talking doing what
he's doing he's also selling the guy who
runs this state called Florida what's
his name his name is Rhonda Sanchez I
know that guy right that he just came
out with a book Ron DeSantis and I don't
know if you read his book in his book
it's interesting New York Times just did
a article about his book of course New
York time has to trash his book it's
what they do for a living but here's
what New York Times said five takeaways
from this book The Scientist avoids
clashing with Donald Trump the Santa's
Praises Trump for bringing a unique uh
star power to the 20 2016 campaign he
criticizes the Russia investigation and
mostly blames Dr Anthony fauci and other
health experts for federal government's
initial response to the coronavirus
pandemic uh yeah because Russia was fake
and fauci and them were wrong okay for
the way they handled it and Florida
showed that they did it the right way
not some other states now again that is
my opinion a lot of numbers can show
that but that's the first part second
descent is underplays Trump's influence
it's widely accepted that Trump's
support was critical to census victory
in 2018 race for governor but DeSantis
presents a different take his debate
performance was the Clincher he writes I
disagree I read the book The Santa
specifically said that President Trump
one time before DeSantis even announced
he's running he asked them for a favor
to say something Trump tweeted about the
scientists saying if he ever ran he
would be great prior to him announcing
then DeSantis announced that he's
running for governor and then when it's
getting close when the debate happened
between him and um
Andrew Gillum uh yeah not Gillum the one
the Republican uh Charlie Chris not
Charlie Chris no no the Santa is the
first one he went with not yeah 2018.
Andrew Gillum is it gives me 18. okay so
he's going against Gilman they're having
the debate and then it comes to the
point where he needs an endorsement then
Trump tweeted again so he gave credit to
Trump supporting him twice in the book
so whatever New York Times is saying if
a person if the average person doesn't
read the book they're going to say oh
did you see what he did in the book he
clearly states if it wasn't for those
tweets that would have not been the same
so he gave credit I just want to make
sure people know that number three the
Santa sees the covet Pivot Point when
2020 got uh underway I was merely a
state Governor entering his second year
in office to census rights within six
months I would emerge as one of the
leading anti-lockdown elected officials
in the world yeah that's a pretty big
decision number four DeSantis boast of
his use of executive power both critics
and courts have rebuked the governor for
executive overreach but the sentences
unbowed he writes proudly about
promising to overly overrule any major
that did not want to host Ultimate
Fighting Championship events during the
pandemic the book touts his removal of
the elected prosecutor in Tampa a
Democrat and he called state budget
vetoes a source of a leverage against
GOP lawmakers who do not want to face
primaries he explains all of that in the
book this is the way there you were
going to say something no say don't
forget about Point number one it's not
just the UFC where did the NBA that's
right where did the Super Bowl
where did AOC go for vacation for
Christmas right
does not dish anyone looking for inside
insight into the famously close off
Governor will be disappointed the census
offers a few behind the scenes details
and skips over some parts of his
biography entirely including the 2016
run for U.S Senate he does write about
Mary and his wife Casey at Disney world
but without Mickey Mouse or Donald Duck
in our wedding photos you know I will
tell you this from reading it
you know how the book was written I've
worked with people like the scientists
in my career and people like the
scientists in my career that I've met
they're very uh they're very uh they're
both structured like let me tell you
this is the kind of guy that from 25
years ago he was careful on every text
and email that he wrote because he knows
this day was coming got you okay this is
the guy that's very methodical who gets
in who's close I can probably tell you
he probably doesn't have 40 friends
that's the kind of guy that probably has
two to five friends Max is what the
Santa's got and that's intentional this
is not a guy that trusts a lot of
different people this is not a guy that
lets a lot of people into his life so if
a person says things like that would I
say yeah they're right yeah if you read
the book there's some parts of it where
he's aloof he's not giving you a lot but
that's because that's his personality
I mean that's think about having no
vision that Focus that dedication path
from all those years to know that all
those years later it's going to come to
a point where you're not going to have
that grab them by the you know what
moment or the this or the text or the
you're just a clean cut you hope oh
don't get me wrong if he is the front
guy the left is 100 gonna find some [__]
because they have people looking at that
right now for Trump number two if you
know if you know he's running and For
The Senses but it's going to be way more
difficult to find it on this guy bro I
found way more difficult I found that
reviewed by the times a little more
balanced than I would have expected from
the times but there is one thing that
they they they need to go look in the
mirror catch a little reflection oh he
abuses executive power it's the New York
Times that's been asking Biden to use
the executive order pen against
conservatives for the past two years and
they were pushing Obama last day in
office to do you know certain executive
orders so let's let's calm down on that
part of it because that's the way this
game is played exactly
yeah obviously he's um he's kind of what
he did with talking about these five
points right here he's basically saying
thanks Trump but no thanks exactly like
appreciate it uh what he does here with
Point number two like he's saying he
thinks you got me in 2018. but thanks
I'm kind of this way now but no no
disrespect he's kind of not talking
trash out there even though Trump
you talk about what's going on he leaked
that picture of Ron the sanctimonious
with underage girls like Trump's gotta
have some more stuff up his Playbook I
think at the end of the day if you're
asking just any old average American
um what they think that uh DeSantis sort
of represents freedom and Trump is more
the chaos candidate and uh that's not
who's going to be uh in the primary I
mean uh but for a general election you
know what I saw today I think it was on
Vanity Fair or I saw it on uh Economist
or one of them where it said Trump can
still be president even if he's uh
convicted or he's charged or he's this
that's kind of what they were saying
really yeah so so there is listen there
is a lot of fear is this the one yeah
here it is this is from who can you tell
me who this is from ABC ABC Trump could
still be elected president if indicted
or convicted experts say okay so let me
ask you why would ABC write this article
why why would you put the heat on on who
on Trump they want to keep the heat on
Trump they want to keep people revved up
attacking Trump they don't want people
they do not want people to back off they
that's that's the last thing they want
oh he's been indicted he can't go so you
back off and what that does that clears
the runway for DeSantis not to have to
build momentum and not have to deal with
the Trump conflict
yeah I think to me am I making ABC stuff
too smart no I get it I I think I think
it shows signs of weakness and fear that
Trump could win
I think this so shows signs of fear that
Trump could win okay uh and and they
have to kind of mentally get ready did
you see the article about the fact that
Democrats are thinking they got to get
Michelle Obama in the mix do we have
that article or no Rob which page is
that one in do you know about uh
Michelle Obama called that phone she's
our only hope there it is uh page 10
there's a story about Michelle Obama uh
uh for president United States in 2024
behind the scenes Democrats are modeling
the best leader for the party who could
win against former president Donald
Trump in 2024 amongst the names of
possible contenders former late First
Lady Michelle Obama who's at who's 59
years old and with her it Factor could
emerge as a top candidate however she
has repeatedly denied any interest in
seeking office some high-level Democrats
are rallying to uh President Biden's
re-election not because they think it's
the best interest of the country to have
an 82 year old start a second term but
because they fear the potential
alternative the nomination of Kamala
Harris and election of Donald Trump
other possible candidates include those
who Supreme obviously won the Democratic
presidential nomination such as Hillary
Clinton John Kerry Al Gore but they
failed to address the concerns of some
voters who want a younger president as
Clinton 75 Kerry 79 Gore
74. she's 59. she's a very very
formidable candidate 100. huge
formidable huge she's huge no I don't
is there any indication any what that
she's even interested in running it
doesn't I don't I'm not I don't think
it's I don't think there's anything
that's uh that she's given no indication
that she's gonna be running I don't
think she's running I think it's I think
there's some hope for her to run I think
if you're looking if you're a Democrat
and you're looking at Biden you're like
all right buddy God keep it moving
sleepy Joe you might this is sort of
Wishful Thinking sort of re-emergence or
Renaissance of Obama and her husband
will be in the white house I don't see
it I've seen nothing of it she keeps
putting getting pulled in in the polls
for the top five topic I just there's
nothing she is she announced at him and
she was up running against would you
vote for her I'm until I see a candidate
that I think is
a better candidate than Ron DeSantis I'm
in The Descendants and I respect you for
that we talked about that even over
Michelle Obama bro like but here's my
Adam I think there could be a moment
because we'll think about it we're not
we're the audience Pat you everybody in
here we're not stupid Joe Biden is not
in charge of anything the real people
the real Democrats that are part of the
democratic party Obama's in there with
Hillary in them I'm telling you right
now if they get scared to a point where
they're like hey guys this cat's not
going to win maybe uh newsom's not
really the guy we're gonna have to pull
the trigger and say listen Michelle we
love you we know you don't want to do it
because you're selling out Arenas just
talking about God knows what we need you
to run why would she say no they need
her if your husband's like yo the party
needs you we can make our change we can
make our policies make our things I
think she'd say yes 100 but by the way
first first let's ask this question the
first question is would you put her at
the top of the list on the left that's
the most formidable if if she ran 100 is
she above Newsome think like a Democrat
her last name you agree I think I think
at the top you have Michelle and Newsome
and if you have want me to handicap
between the two I think it's 60 40 and
she's 60 and she's 40. on the top two
perfect and I don't care about anybody
else and stop talking about Kamala
Harris the big money and the DNC want
her to go away yesterday perfect so yeah
yeah so so every time he stumbles the
story she told about conservatives
concerns yeah she's almost when she does
that off of diarrhea I have to go to the
restroom but but let me hear you talk
about space because space you know space
space is so vast that's why they call it
Ace here's a question yeah here's a
question if Michelle Obama did you agree
that she is the most formidable on the
left I don't what do you think is uh
uh formidable yeah
I think
formidable yes you still have to put
Biden on the list because he's the
incumbent president do I think he's a
formidable in general no but but
currently fine but then I would put
Gavin Newsom up there head on the Shelf
uh yes Michelle's not anywhere even on
my top 10 list me personally really you
might be like I'm crazy that's nuts and
she's given no indication why though
she's done nothing
this is not an indication question this
is a question of she's African-American
she's the wife of Barack Obama she's not
really a first lady she was seen as a
partner yes of Barack Obama she is
strong on the left they love her Oprah
Hollywood music Beyonce there's a lot of
different things there right she's a
dancer okay so so you're not saying
whether she's formidable Mark you just
don't think she's gonna run I'm just you
know there's nothing that's basically
motivating me to give two shits about
Michelle Obama right now yeah but that's
not the question no I get it I wouldn't
go to Michelle Obama rally I don't know
what she stands for she's never let
anything you're gonna you're gonna she's
the wife of a president in my eyes
that's it do you realize like even the
AV people didn't go to Biden's rally
they left
the audio visual people that were
working the mic they just left because
they said no one's going to be here yeah
okay let's play this game with Michelle
Obama why would Michelle Obama if you're
sitting there with her you're at her
house she trusts you you're somebody
with her in a Barack you're having
dinner you and four other people that
she trusts and you say Michelle why do
you not want to run she's gonna say what
I just want to be a mother I enjoy being
a wife I enjoy your life
is good money's good we are living
low-key we get to do whatever we want to
do I'm enjoying my years with my husband
we got plenty of you know years left in
us and what we want to do I just don't
want to do it okay so then you have to
go through the concerns my schedule so
now the other person's got to sell on
and say what if we could put a team
together around you where you can still
do a lot of things you want to do
but we go out there and do this and we
do a one-term thing right now because
the only reason we do it one term is
because Trump's probably not going to
run four years from now do one term
let's pick a VP let's give the VP to
whoever else anyways the conversation
about how to sell her to run what she
doesn't have to give up the life do you
sell The Supporting Cast or do you sell
the history or do you sell America
Democrats need you what do you sell what
do you sell to Michelle for her to run I
don't think you ever go up to somebody
like that and say America needs you do
us a favor I think you sell her on cause
precedent and Legacy you'll be the first
female president you will be you will be
able to set a chart for a lot of the
things that you believed in and you were
working on do you remember when you
cried the afternoon the inauguration
because you you said you felt like you
were giving up your the the momentum
that you had on the causes Michelle you
can put all the back on the front burner
you're only 59 years old and by the way
America needs you to lead this cause I
sell her on cause and Legacy I think
there's gonna be one problem Pat it's
it's you know the whole thing they're
gonna they're not gonna find one picture
of her on the internet where she's
pregnant here we go and that's going to
be one of the problems I'll put that
that's a challenge for anybody that's
watching you cannot find one photo of
Michelle Obama pregnant online and I'm
telling you right now that's gonna be a
problem where they're gonna go wait a
minute where are you pregnant that's
where you're going to go with this I was
just gonna say people are gonna be like
dude show me one Jenny I know you love
these types of stories
out there I'm gonna address the
questions even if even if there's
there's no pictures here's a question
for you yeah objectively we're playing
fantasy football elect the president
you have to be the Democrat captain
sell me on selling her to do it
um I'm taking you as my quarterback to
have uh Michelle do it you're talking to
Michelle you're selling Michelle on
doing it run Michelle I would say let's
listen uh first of all the way that it's
looking the guy that's in charge right
now we're gonna lose we're gonna lose
everything with this guy you're gonna be
the savior of the party look what your
husband did look at the look at your
legacy look at your family we need you
because the way that it's looking Guess
who's coming back Trump I'm telling you
and if you don't like Trump trump light
is going to be the Santa's we need you
your husband needs you like I think you
guys got it all wrong I don't think so
and I'll tell you why
there's nothing to sell her on
either she wants to do it or she doesn't
that's my opinion you don't think her
husband has any hear me out you don't
think Barack Obama's gonna be a
conversation between her and Obama
and you know hey you're 6'10 you're a
big guy you should be of NBA power
forward you should work it's like yeah I
don't I don't I don't want to play
basketball you're not gonna sell
somebody to want to do something how
many sales guys we have upstairs the
work of value shout out to them yeah hey
if you do this you can make this amount
of money I promise it's the life of your
dreams yeah I don't really want to make
cold calls there's nothing that shows me
that she has the heart and the
fierceness to want to do this no one has
to sell her on this if she she needs to
sell herself or need she needs to look
in the mirror or have a conversation
with her husband was the two-term
president and there's nothing that I'm
seeing that she wants this Trump
he [__] wants this like him or not he
wants this DeSantis is heading that
direction where you know behind closed
doors he's like I can do this okay even
Biden had to kind of get pushed into it
he didn't want to run against Hillary
2016. now he's there was nothing to sell
this time around he kind of got sold
this time there's nothing to sell
Michelle Obama she either wants it or
she doesn't and in my mind she does not
want this job okay she don't want this
smoke she doesn't want Adam but the
reason she is who she is is because the
Democratic party's husband is made her
you would never have known who she was
this is going to be okay you don't think
he has no say in this like hey we need
we need you all this is going to be very
controversial and I hate to do this on
International women's day what okay
Obama's the man he's the husband he's
the president okay she's a first lady
that's it Melania hottest first lady
ever I don't need her [__] run in the
country okay that's it that's the extent
of what I think of Michelle Obama
I disagree with that I challenge you to
go back and look at the origins of
Melania origins of Michelle Obama
Michelle Obama was not some model of
hottie Communications major at College
she's a lawyer she was formidable they
were working together in Chicago one
thing she's got cause on her heart and
that's why I say cause precedent Legacy
that's how I sell it you're absolutely
right that she's not just some Slovenian
model that showed up for to be a third
wife very hot okay she got that choose a
hypothetical example I know exactly I I
got that part no doubt she they met in
law school I get it you either want this
fight or you don't want this fight
there's nothing that I see about
Michelle Obama that she wants this at
all listen I would bring Ryan Gosling
and I would have him stand in front of
her and say what do you want what do you
want yeah and then we would watch the
notebook and we would say let's go build
that white house for you Michelle you're
a percentage guy and I value exactly
because you're not you're gonna go down
Vinnie conspiracy Lane that's not a
conspiracy find I'll find the photo of
her pregnant what are your chances not
her electability is high no doubt that
she wants to do this she wants to that
no it that she would do this less than
100 okay so you're at less than one I'm
less than one percent all right so
you're in Sussex Camp No I said she
don't want this no no it's not it's not
she doesn't want this listen there are
honestly there are certain jobs
that you don't get to choose if you want
to do it or not it's it's a calling it's
a the conversation is like okay when you
get a call say somebody becomes a
president they say Adam
your your worth 70 million bucks it's 20
years from now you're 60 years old okay
Adam I need you to come in and be the
secretary or whatever or I need you to
do this we need your help on this part
here and it's a guy that you respect a
lot and he's done a lot for you and
you're like dude I'm married I got kids
listen I'm telling you right now I need
you
this is not a call to ask you I'm
telling you I need you
so I'm not recruiting you I'm telling
you
you're the right guy for this job and I
know you like the country club lifestyle
I know you've been chilling I know you
like to get on that boat I know you like
doing all this stuff totally get it bro
but America is bigger than you and I and
I need you right now so when can I get
you to come to DC for us to have this
conversation together
that's the phone call you would get from
me if I was the guy there so if the
people she respect the conversation is
we kind of need you right now here's
what's going on there's a difference
when you're called versus a job to do
this is not a job this is a calling so I
don't know I would take a different
approach with her uh if it came down to
it but at this point of the game uh who
knows maybe if we're all of a sudden
somebody out of nowhere like a mayor
Laurie Lightfoot could come in and say I
want to be
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
there's a job opening so let's go let's
go to page number six Tom I'm gonna give
this one to you what's going on with
India iPhone maker plan 700 million
dollar plant in India to shift away from
China this is a Bloomberg story Apple
Inc partner Fox con Technology Group
plans to invest 700 million dollars in a
new plant in India to make phones uh
parts and possibly assemble handsets on
a 300 Acre Site close to
Bengaluru airport according to Anonymous
sources the investment is one of
foxconn's biggest single outlays in
India to date and may be used to produce
some parts for its uh nascent electric
vehicle business the factory is expected
to create a hundred thousand jobs and
marks a shift of manufacturing away from
China and the tensions between us and
China India has offered Financial
incentives to Apple suppliers and the
move away may help the country close its
Tech Gap with Chinatown
people need to think about India this
way it's kind of the same shape
India is the Texas of foreign
manufacturing they are trying to attract
a lot away from California which is
China that's what's going on here and
Foxconn so India's government is trying
to do that and Foxconn is hedging a bet
because they see risk in China and they
also get a lot of blowback right now
from the United States on Chinese
manufacturing this is a this I believe
is one of the early shots in what's
going to be an insane War over the next
10 years economically for the
manufacturing center and there's only
one country on Earth that has population
that starts with a B that China fears
and it is India
yep I've been saying that for I agree
with you I've been saying that for a
minute I think India is a uh the country
they go to sleep fearing the most
because India says we don't fear you we
don't give a [__] what you think about
it Adam do you have any thoughts on this
yeah I mean it's it's good to see that
these big manufacturers are moving away
from China and everything they've done
to steal our intellectual property uh I
think modi's been in in charge since
what 2014 give or take so he's doing his
thing out there and then uh you know the
only thing cheaper than uh
underage Chinese laborers young Indian
labor I mean you're being wrong I mean
being honest sounds like India is the
new home of child labor I mean he's
being so these these pennies are not
there because they give two shits they
want to make money yeah so uh it hurts
but you know it's cheaper than Chinese
yeah it wasn't the companies coming in
running sweatshops this is the Indian
government giving Financial incentives
for 300 freaking acres and a hundred
thousand jobs that's pretty freaking
meaningful that's amazing that's great
Vinnie give us your Insight from the AI
standpoint from the AI standpoint
robots are going to take over that thing
in 20 years 100
in India oh yeah but speaking of age is
really fast I know we have we have you
know January 6 and all that to talk
about have you been seeing the fake uh
where they're having Biden speak and
it's not Joe Biden and the it's scary
it's on top of a deep fake it's the
voice if you close your eyes it's so
accurate I'm saying right now in 10
years when they perfect it you're not
gonna know who the hell called you and
told you to come here or give you this
or or or or or you didn't say that or
you said something racist it's going to
be a fake AI saying that you said it
it's going to be almost impossible to
prove that it was you I can't wait to
meet your fake AI oh my God I mean have
you heard them Pat look at them is this
steak are you familiar with the 2011
film We Bought a Zoo the Matt Damon
picture scarjo is in it as well although
her performance isn't anything to shake
a stick at if I'm being honest like it
was directed by Cameron Crowe the fellow
who made Jerry Maguire
show me the money
anyway and so I was watching We Bought a
Zoo a few days ago
if they perfect that how much better
does that sound then I like being in a
pool with kids and they rub on the leg
and all my like what the that sounds
presidential by the way that could help
him in 2020. 100 percent no by the way
all he has to do is he has to like go
like this
like can you see my mouth what I'm
saying as long as they can't see my
mouth you just be like yeah put on a
mask the microphone
another pandemic comes put on the map by
the way did you see what the mayor of uh
New York said Adams no with all the
camera when they're capturing all these
guys that are going in with Eric Adams
that they're going in with uh with masks
on he says moving forward we have to
remove masks in New York because we
can't catch criminal anymore are you
kidding me how funny how funny is that
how freaking funny is that he's in the
documentary yes for years mayor Adams to
New York City Shoppers drop that Mass to
prevent rivalries mayor Eric Adams
telling shot people good bar customers
brilliant who refuse to lower their
masks you would think this is a Babylon
B story but it's not who is this by the
way New York Times oh can you zoom in so
we can see the logo at the time it's a
freaking New York Times story I'm like
what
yo you know what Colvin made me realize
what mask in California it was never
really that serious wearing a mask
inside of a bank I would wear the whole
cover and I'll nobody's security is like
yeah comment nobody nobody cared and
then covert hit people like that put on
your cover your face come into the bank
so it's not even a big freaking deal
did you you know how rare it is for
Walmart to close doors you know how rare
it is for Walmart to close a store okay
Walmart and one of their blue cities
that they're in okay there's only those
are going to say okay here we go on
Thursday company spokesperson come from
two locations in Portland Oregon I
wonder why they're going in there taking
products leaving you can't do [__] about
it yeah Portland Walmart closures
attract national attention Wheeler Texas
governor Albert spars with uh and and
the way they put it it's like well you
know they're having a hard time but look
at the story Walmart last month
announced it's closing two of its
Portland stores but it's drawn a fresh
round of attention this week as
politicians part uh online over the
cause the detailed giant will lay off
580 employees when the stores close
March 24th according to a regulatory
discussion here are five things to know
about the closures whose article is this
by the way there's no single live.com
oregonlive.com so why is Walmart closing
some are saying it's because Walmart's
uh not having a lot of business some are
saying because they're being robbed and
they're like there's no profit yeah so
why is he getting so much attention
they're going back and forth go a little
lower to see the data on this one here
go a little lower so you said is
Governor Abbott who took aim at Portland
over the issue saying the closure is
what happens when cities refuse to
enforce the rule of law exactly Portland
Oregon out of all the cities like it's
not like it's Dallas Texas yeah and
Walmart rarely ever closes stores I've
never seen for Walmart to say we quit
that says a lot about your city whoever
the mayor of Portland is when you lose
Walmart that's like when you were to
coach when LeBron or Michael or Kobe
says I'm leaving your team how the hell
do you lose Walmart
your God City that's the were they the
same as uh New York and Cali where it's
like under a thousand bucks you just
they don't give a [__] they're not gonna
they're not even gonna stop sorry
California's lowering it from a thousand
I believe Portland OR California is
lowering it from a thousand to four
fifty two great minimize perfect but to
Walmart how many people leave with 450.
yeah I don't [__] you're thinking TV
exactly that's the what is the number
it's uh yeah they lowered it from a
thousand dollars to 450 I can find the
article here anyway whatever let's go
into this next story here card that
piles up as more Americans struggle to
make car payments okay we talked about
this last time and it created a lot of
Buzz a rising number of Americans are
struggling to keep up with their car
payments hello indicating Financial
stress amid High car prices and
persistent inflation the percentage of
auto borrowers who were at least 60 days
behind on their bills Rose two percent
from December at 20.4 percent a year ago
while loan defaults increased 6.2
percent over January and we're up 33 and
a half percent over a year ago although
the high level of severe delinquencies
has not led to equivalent growth and
defaults reposition rates have climbed
the number of repossessed cars increased
11 percent in 2022 compared to the
previous year the rapid increase in auto
loans rates to 6.9 in January up from
4.3 percent a year ago that's a 50
increase by the way a little over 50
increase and high carb prices averaging
nearly 50 000 have made it harder for
Americans to make car payments with many
monthly payments above what did we talk
about last time a thousand dollars
Rising interest rates and High car
prices threaten the Auto industry shoot
a more consumer defaults on their loans
it's coming it's just a matter of time
go ahead Tom it's it's basically here I
mean this is we talk about Upstream
problems and downstream problems
Downstream as you look about a bunch of
things Downstream the pond is polluted
and the Democrats say let's make a one
billion dollar filter and drop it into
the lake Republicans say let's go
upstream and find out what the hell is
in the river that's filling up the lake
well this is an upstream Downstream
problem Upstream interest rates have
been going on up since March of 22
that's was that's when uh Powell first
met the cheerleader and and so now those
are up and then we saw last week that
the average car had gone from 40 to 50
000 on average price on a on a basic low
end you know good solid good mileage
good safe basic car with nice features
and this is basically Downstream it's
coming home to roast the repossessed
cars is up 11 but the loan defaults have
only come up six percent but they're
increasing this is accelerating and if
inflation is not under control this is
going to get worse and as inflation
comes down unfortunately you're going to
see unemployment come up the people that
are in that unemployment in a low line
it's going to come up so basically let
me translate this for you if you want to
buy a car you know hang on for a few
months because the price of the used
cars are going to come down because the
supply of used cars has to go up with
what's happening oh my God go ahead Adam
well we talk a lot about how like
college is a scam you know does college
outdated you know the government got
involved student loans I mean we can go
on for days the Alternatives rather than
going to college
I would argue that the car industry and
car loans and car debt is by far a
greater scam than College
people are still in the 1980s mindset
that you need a car it's like there are
so many Alternatives these days to
driving yourself into debt I mean look
at the numbers two out of three
Americans are paycheck to paycheck
housing prices are skyrocketing foods
are uh inflation you know you want to
buy an egg the other day it was like uh
12 bucks for a dozen done the the the
car situation is I've been saying this
for years everyone knows I haven't had a
car for over a decade
what a sham Adam yeah go have a family
bro hurry up please hurry up and have
kids back you imagine that and then
and ironically twist of fate by the time
that happens I'll have a lot of money in
the bank and I'll get whatever car I
want can you imagine this and it's all
good Adam right now with kids like kids
you want to go to soccer practice hold
on I gotta get an Uber yeah
I actually uh Florida rainstorms it
comes up in 30 seconds but I I will give
you I'll get obviously as a single guy
single guy you have a car it's easy to
when you don't have a family you don't
have to to discuss the seven things but
for the people with families out there
I'll give I'll give a case example a guy
I was working with he was like the
handyman in my building where I lived in
Miami he was struggling he didn't like
where he lived he was living out in
Kendall which is like an outside of
Miami
handyman what was his pronoun
[Laughter]
and what he did was he said you know
what these [__] car prices are insane
I got two cars I got kids I got this I
had that I said you're living a hot
you're 45 minutes an hour from work
because you're you're way outside of
Miami I said where do you want to be
he's like I'd love to live downtown what
did he do he sold one of his cars
him and his him and his wife and kid
sold one of the cars and got it out of
his life moved downtown now he lived
five minutes from work he would just
Uber to work okay his wife had the car
all day if they needed a car for the kid
they had it but the point is they
figured it out they weren't like well
we're a two family a two kid person and
now we have two cars that's just cookie
cutter they they realize that there's
things they could do but we saw them
were all in secret dude I agree they did
that wrong did that for a long time they
did that with one car both of them and
they crushed it it was good and they had
two kids so there's there's ways to do
that but Adam the day
you
and the content's Gonna Change when
you're talking on the podcast and you're
gonna say Adam how was your night ah not
good Junior didn't let me sleep I'm on
an hour and a half and you're
complaining and grouchy and all that's
this that's what the content's gonna get
juicy I agree yeah but uh but we were
not there yet we made an ad video
yesterday you guys walked in I was
making a video of both of you guys saw
this thing this thing's gonna be
launched here soon for uh we'll see it's
it's a very it's a very interesting ad
video that we have to kind of release to
people but not right now so anyways FYI
real quick with Matt Walsh when Stephen
Crowder was on uh uh I said you know I
made a comment about the fact that hey
um
what I say I said what what what do we
there's levels to the game what do I
need to do to be able to see Future
Family emergencies happening from
canceling I know I'm not at your level
yet Crowder I call them out and Matt
Walsh and I said Matt Walsh also did it
because today is the international
women's day yes and the guy who wrote
and made the documentary what is a woman
we wanted him to come and teach us what
a woman is that's why we did it on
International women's it was a very
appropriate day yeah and uh I said hey
you know Matt Walsh canceled as well
last minute etc etc uh anyways uh his
team reached out he texted me he
communicated with me he is going through
a it's a private he shared it with me I
respect him for doing that for him not
to be here we're looking forward to
having him on hopefully one of these
days we'll have them on to have a
conversation with him I think his work
is very necessary I think what he did
got a lot of people to ask questions and
for parents who have girls I think he
did a major service to a lot of families
to produce that documentary what is a
woman it was one that he got a lot of
hate for or I respect them for it but
this is my style of doing business for
anybody that maybe in the future books
us to be on a podcast and all of a
sudden can't make it call me before just
tell me can I talk to Pat the host Pat
here's what's going on I don't want it
to be bad here's what's going to be
happening I can't make it because that's
what I would do to you if I cannot make
it that's what I'm asking for anybody in
the future if they see it if they hear
it the same way I don't like onions yeah
the same way I don't like the smell of
onions or shaking hands but people smoke
cigarettes this is one of my pet peeves
obviously Tom knows nothing about this
but it is what it is but okay if I could
just say just to your credit I see your
schedule you're flying you're in you're
out like you're taking time out of your
day by the way this is what they don't
know you know I'm not supposed to be
here today I know you're flying out of
town I think no no I'm not supposed to
be here today because this is spring
break because where am I going right
after this uh you know the Bahamas I got
a flight in 30 minutes
I changed the schedule just because of
Matt wash Dylan Antico are right there
right now by your desk I've been playing
on my desk I'm not supposed to be in
town today I was was only staying in
time for Matt Walsh that's the part
where when you're running an 80-hour
week schedule we're not doing this
because we we're doing this because
we're running businesses as well but it
is what it is okay I don't want to say
that but it's all good your schedule is
busy I appreciate that I don't want to
put that out schedule version of hangry
all right so let's go through a couple
different things here that we got here
let's go to the let's go to what
happened with this trending topic on
Twitter which is what it's uh the
genuine Tucker Carlson is a liar it is
trending right now on Twitter it keeps
getting more and more and more so I'll
read the story I'll show a clip from
Kevin McCarthy what I I think I just
texted it to you if you have it please
get that ready and then Vinnie I'm going
to come to you first because you look
like you've been chomping I'm chomping
you've been you've been waiting for this
time someone will kind of go through it
all right and you look good Dr Carlson
releases exclusive January 6 footage
says politicians media light about
signic cunan shamanan Shaman Tucker
Carlson release date is pushed by he
says in January 6 20 21 writes that
challenges various narratives pushed by
the Democratic control house select
committee on mainstream media the
footage shows Trump's supporters
peacefully touring the building
contradicting the news coverage of
January 6th that likened the event to 9
11 and the attacks on Pearl Harbor
Capitol police officers were seen
escorting Jacob chansley the Q Anon
Shaman around the building without
incident Carlson reported that officers
were seen showing chance Lee Iran even
trying to open lock doors for him the
footage also challenges The Narrative
that the events of January 6 were a
deadly Insurrection officer Brian
cisnick was seen walking normally while
guiding Trump supporters out of the
building while wearing a helmet which
contradicts the media narrative that he
died of a head injury so this is this
now everyone's saying stuff about Tucker
negatively I mean blowing up I can't
believe he said this I can't believe he
said that did you get the clip I sent
you about what Kevin McCarthy said I
don't have it do you have it if you
don't have it let me just send it to you
so you have I texted it to myself if you
go to uh let me send this to you you
have to see this while we're pulling
this up Vinnie why don't you give us
your thoughts and then I'll go to Kevin
so and I want to ask everybody I want to
ask you Pat Rob all the you know
everybody everybody in chat uh what was
the reason for the January 6th situation
and mind you I call it a situation
because it wasn't an Insurrection
Insurrection is a violent Uprising
against the government or authority let
me explain something for everybody that
saw what's happening especially with
Tucker it was none of that all right so
and when I asked why Pat why did the
people go to the to the Capitol it's a
rhetorical question why why they go
because those people that the election
was stolen from them and my question is
Pat is that such a far-fetched idea for
them to think that the left would do
something like that all right and you
know what the answer is no Pat they've
lied the left and the government they
lied about Russia they lied about covet
they lied about scenes they lied about
Hunter Biden they lied about the Border
they lied about China
the audacity to be like how how dare you
guys question us it's like bro shut the
shut the hell up and then you have
um Schumer it's left and right Schumer
and Mitch McConnell the alien going hey
Fox don't you dare show this and Pat why
not let us see the truth and you know
the people that died Pat it was the
Ashley Babbitt was one of the ones that
was murdered she was a United States Air
Force veteran Air Force veteran unarmed
she was shot and murdered by a capital
police that's one and that Brian
sicknick who was wearing a helmet they
said was killed with blunt floors trauma
he had a stroke okay so it wasn't what
they tried to say that it was these
people were there because you know what
they don't believe the government and
this is my thing I'm actually not proud
but impressed you know what when you
have a problem and you think the
government is effing with you that's
what you go to the government you don't
burn down your city you don't kill your
own people you don't burn down
businesses in your town like remember
with the riots people were burning down
BLM antifa they burned down their own
City if you have a problem with
authority go to the authority and from
what I saw Tom that Shaman was walking
around smiling taking uh selfies talking
to people they had ropes escorting
people into where and what about working
slowly and they would touch him on the
shoulder to say no this way and they
would open the door for him he was
waiting at doors and they're like hang
on a second open this for you and you're
looking and it says wait a minute
because he was wearing that headdress
and the fur it they the media used that
as there's a psycho person this is part
of the Insurrection but the truth was
yeah he was wearing a headdress with the
fur but he was walking around it looked
like a guided tour field trip and uh uh
Ray Epps who Christy one of our writers
in here wrote about a pet she said
Insurrection or fed selection it was one
of those things uh everybody thought the
guy was the FBI agent and in court they
showed his text you know what he told
his his nephew he goes I orchestrated
the protest at the Capitol he goes I
help people get there that's that guy
that was wearing the Trump hat and was
yelling at people to go this is when
we're gonna go and we're gonna attack
the capital and why isn't that guy in
jail if you give four years to the
shaman guy that was on a tour of the
Capitol but Ray Epps the guy that was
inciting violence and guess what I don't
trust them so good for them they should
have you know what it shouldn't have
happened on January 6 when they found
out these people with Russian collusion
it was all the hoax with Hitler in the
government light that's when they were
late y'all you guys should have gone
there a year earlier two years earlier
and gone and talked [__] so I'm I'm not
for violence but I'm for if you have a
problem with the government go talk to
the [__] government don't burn down
your own City that's my point Tom
thoughts uh
I'm just listening to this and I'm
Vinnie I thank you for your passion I
mean thank you I was disappointed and
shocked and what came to my mind was
they freaking lied to the public about
this guy and they railroaded him this
guy is throwing three years four four
actually and apparently he's got uh a a
a couple psychomedical issues you know
and real issues and so this guy got
railroaded all the footage that we see
now I understand why all the committee
members didn't want Fox to put this up
because it immediately shows that
Capitol Police and the prosecution took
this guy and put him in jail because he
looked funny and was walking around with
a headdress and it fit the narrative I
was incredibly disappointed when I when
I saw this yesterday there he is look
it's on a tour where's the Insurrection
where is him stop he's gonna come back
yeah and like dude the guy was on a
freaking field trip that was with roped
off and guided around like yes guess
what there were some Hooligans every
every time you get hundreds of people
together look at this
two cops in the call let them go in and
they said that security detail in the
orange vest look at that now he's gonna
walk through here look the cop behind
them where's the violence this guy dude
you know how many people are in solitary
confinement right now you know how many
people are not going to see the light of
day so so let me let me show this can
you show me what Chuck Schumer's
reaction was to this it's very different
than what Vinnie said I just texted it
to you if you can play Chuck Schumer's
reaction here's Schumer's reaction
these lies shall continue tonight
Rupert Murdoch who has admitted they
were lies and said he regretted it has a
special obligation
to stop Tucker Carlson from going on
tonight now that he's seen how he is
perverted and slimed through truth yeah
and from letting him go on again and
again and again
not because their views deserve such a
program
but because our democracy depends on it
let me guess our democracy depends on
Tucker not showing this let me explain
something to you the threat does maybe
there's going to be a real Insurrection
when the people see what's happening Tom
here's my question what is wrong Pat
would just let me see I guess the 40 000
hours they picked just those type of
moments what are you what are you so
scared of what is the fear and letting
me see like what's happening it's like
there's a Pruder for him well they're
like like out of everybody one guy
recorded it people the government was
like no no they tried not to show it let
me see it so I can make my own decision
I don't need Chuck Schumer I don't need
Mitch McConnell to tell me what I can
and what I can't see can you play can
you play Kevin McCarthy's video
can you play Kevin McCarthy what his
reaction because of the footage that you
gave
last night he went on so this is a
mostly peaceful chaos as he's
as he's downplayed Brian sicknick's
death said it was not related January
6th so this was not an Insurrection do
you regret giving him this footage so he
can whitewash the events of that thing
like no uh I I said at the very
beginning transparency and so what I
wanted to produce for everybody is
exactly what I said that people could
actually look at it and see what's good
for you good for you
is this portrayal of what happened look
each person come up with their own
conclusion make sure as I had
transparency because I know in CNN I
mean I had here where you guys actually
broke where we were this was a secret
wow I don't know if you got concerned by
that I don't even know from uh point of
view of security if we could ever be
taken there again but when you broke
that CNN that was a real concern to a
lot of people I had a real concern also
when I wanted to make sure transparency
look
um the officer's death Is tragically
anytime an officer is passed in this
situation uh I want to make sure either
protected I want to make sure the
transparency as it goes forward
this in any way part of the deal that
you made to win the speakership
specifically give the content today
if you follow I'm not sure if you were
there the times before I got asked the
question
um in a press what I would do in the
process I've watched on January 6
committee how it was only political
Improvement now on the January 6
committee you couldn't have the minority
side wasn't allowed to put people on
um and I just thought it was fair if
someone asked me the question just
transparency so what I try to do is be
able to release the information which
we'll do to everybody it's good I worked
that's like I mean Pat do you know you
know what that is you know why the left
is so pissed off it's like how dare you
change our narrative that we've been
sitting on to try to get Trump not to
run again that's exactly what the hell
you're seeing and good from I don't give
a damn about what deal he did that's
ballsing I love the fact that he had an
article right in front of your face CNN
giving our location because you guys
wanted us to get hurt so kiss my ass
Adam
um all right Vinnie thank you for your
passion we appreciate that yeah I
actually spent a lot of time watching
Tucker last night watching Hannity last
night I was watching uh CNN last night
just to kind of see different
perspectives here and what is clearer
than ever is that both sides are just
gonna just deliver news that just feeds
their base that just drive their
narrative both sides uh we all know how
easy it is to edit things and that's not
a political statement so whatever Tucker
shows on his show
can be edited same thing goes for CNN so
I think January 6th from an overall
standpoint was a very sad and disgusting
day in a stain on America with that
being said I think the majority of
people there were just generally there
to protest uh the shaman and whatever
clowns broke into the capital they
should be held to the highest extent of
the law period And if they're in jail
for two years three years two two months
whatever it is it's deserved period
um what I what what I'm finding
interesting now is that like that you
can say the January 6 committee sham
nobody on there Lich Chaney Adam
kinzinger you know a bunch of Democrats
it's it's you know people are losing
trust in what the government is and each
media narrative each side of the
narrative is just gonna basically say
what people want to say like so I
believe and I'm just going to use uh
Tucker's words
uh Trumper uh Tucker doesn't like Trump
behind closed doors but he loves his
base so he's trying to thread the needle
of
genuinely appeasing the base but at the
same time distancing himself from Trump
his words you're seeing what's going on
with this whole Dominion lawsuit like
let's not forget that fox is going to be
dealing with some [__] with this
Dominion lawsuit and Murdoch and
everything they said and essentially
they knew that Trump lost the election
but they they kept perpetuating the
story Carlson his words passionately
hates Trump okay and a number of text
messages in November 2020 Carlson said
that Trump's decision to snub Joe
Biden's inauguration was quote unquote
so destructive Tucker Carlson added that
Trump's post-election Behavior was quote
unquote disgusting and that he was
trying to look away from Trump in
another text in a conversation two days
before the January 6 attack
Tucker Carlson said we are very very
close to being able to ignore Trump on
most nights I truly can't wait these are
Tucker's texts last but not least Tucker
added I hate him passionately okay I
actually didn't know this about Tucker I
actually thought that he genuinely liked
Trump but again I think Trump there it
is right there I hate him passionately
these are Tucker Carlson words don't
believe Sal's over here look it up
yourself okay he can't wait for Trump to
be out there but who he does respect and
he does appreciate in Trump's base so
Tucker's trying to thread the needle
distancing himself from Trump and at the
same time appeasing the base and that's
exactly what foxes seems to be doing at
this point but so so Adam you're so
January 6 you're saying one of the most
disgusting you're not on the uh AOC and
all Kamal and all them saying it was
compared to 911 and pearl hold on
because I want to make because I
definitely you don't think it was where
thousands and thousands of people died
and burned and jumped off of buildings
it's took a I hope you're not trying to
say because it was disgusting in your
eyes it was nowhere near that because
that's what they're saying so what's
your question so Mike my question is I
don't I can care less about the Tucker
text and all that stuff we're going I
don't care about editing you're seeing
you just saw it because you can watch
all these videos it wasn't what they an
Insurrection of trying to take over
whatever people were just walking around
and hold on I'm trying to get to your
question yeah so who died like what was
the the are you asking do I think
January 6th is equal to 9 11 is that
your question no I'm just saying well
you you think it was disgusting why do
you think it was so disgusting because
people were thought that what's your
question like you think it was it going
too much to go there and just protest
and a couple of [__] got out of line
that's what it was are you mad about
that okay so let's I don't understand
hang on so let me go through some of the
questions yeah so do you compare the
January 6 to 911 on Pearl Harbor not
even close Okay no he's not there just
so you know no no no the thousands of
people died in these [__] things it's
not even close let's now let's go let's
go to the same okay go ahead sorry at
the same time finish your point go ahead
yeah I mean at the same time it wasn't a
proud moment in American history these
are these are people that should not
been in the capital again if you want to
go and and protest and you want to be
out there waving flags God bless you do
it America do everything but let's stop
pretending that these people were up to
no good okay like the this guy the
shaman should have not been in the
capital that day why was he in there
none of these guys should have been in
there Adam Adam okay so the opposite
argument to that would be during the BLM
protests how many people died 20 to 30 I
think more than that what what have we
heard about it you're right yeah two
things can be true no but the January 6
was disgusting
but that's my point that's what I'm
saying I get that but your point can be
your opinion but it's not the truth
because you have to give it to data
meaning do you know how I said earlier
the four day work week you have to have
a definition of success let's define
success
Define give me a specific definition of
which crisis was bigger Based on data
not opinion data comparing three
different crises if we have how do we
Define which crisis is worse than the
other based on what data
we have deaths hang on I'm asking you
know I'm not asking you guys I'm asking
him I'm sorry so this I I'll answer any
question you ask but I don't feel like
they even need to be compared they're
both shitty situations but that's not
how life works okay listen but that's
January 6 can be a disgusting thing and
the protest could also be discuss the
question though that's not the question
though the question is the following I'm
gonna ask a question one more time it's
a very logical question there's no
emotion behind this thing here okay when
people compare compare LeBron and
Michael and Kobe okay statistically
where does the argument win for LeBron
where does the argument lose for it Kobe
where does the argument lose for MJ so
I'll give you mine Kobe's field goal
percentage was the lowest it's terrible
okay Kobe's field goal percentage is not
good uh to me he is a good
top five best player of all time I don't
put him as a number one or two or three
or four but I have them in the top five
that's my opinion Based on data field
goal percentage takes a hit okay
LeBron James the greatest human specimen
in the history of the league ever ever
did he make the NBA product better or
worse like Michael made I don't know
what did he do to the league the career
in the what do you call it finals is
what he's four and what what's his
record four and six some record like
that in the finals right okay but
statistically most points ever most
assist more rebounds than any of those
guys field goal percentage over 50
percent better three-point shooter great
right Michael Jordan 6-0
all Defensive Player of the Year
defensive player of the year I mean I
can give you a bunch of different things
with him he played 82 games in a season
I think 10 times or eight times in his
career his last year when he played he
played 1882 games I don't know if
LeBron's ever played 82 games in a year
maybe one okay those are data I'm asking
data again question from you again what
specific data makes a crisis worse than
the other
data
you know deaths okay good I agree okay
what else damage to the city property
property damage okay uh what else can we
do we're coming I I didn't know death is
one property damage what else uh death
property damage
would you add anything else or those
those times I would add to I would call
it casualties so death and injured
people people that were absolutely
injured so I would call it casualties
but yes I agree with property I mean
those are those are those are how much
it affects democracy
how much it affects the market that was
sounded like what does that mean though
he's trying to get hit no but no no but
but hang on if if we go Based on data
if we go Based on data the BLM riots and
what they did
supersedes January 6th
in death 25 30 to 1. yes damage to the
city it's not 20 to 1. it's a million to
one yeah because the Insurrection wasn't
any damage to the local businesses or
anything the damage in BLM protests
riots in the streets fires local
businesses getting hit it's not a
thousand to one it's more like to be
honest with you it could be a billion to
one it could be 10 billion to one the
damage to the local business owners this
is data so for for one to be more uh
fanatical to pin one being bigger than
the other that is propaganda that is
manipulative that is deceptive that's
the part the two in regards to Tucker
not liking Trump
uh I'm not surprised that Tucker doesn't
like Trump I'm not surprised that you
think it's like saying does Anderson
Cooper love Joe Biden are you kidding me
I don't know do you think they like Joe
Biden now you think any of these left
people you think Rachel Maddow goes to
sleep saying oh my God I can't wait to
correct the way that my picture of Joe
Biden is in my office when I walk in no
they don't like Joe Biden they can't
stand me for every one text of Tucker
Carlson saying I hate Trump there's
thousands of texts on the other side
saying let's get this freaking whatever
whatever leader out of here Biden
because he's making it horrible for us
let's set that part aside they have
opinions about each other and Trump's
not the one that Tucker likes fine all
I'm saying here is this was overly
promoted by people calling this worse
than 9 11 terrorists all this stuff to
put fear into people and divide America
and they won they did and they wanted to
push this guy out Trump to make sure he
never could run again those are
fanatical things to be saying okay
fanatical things should be saying that's
all I'm saying here I'll give you the
final thoughts we'll go to the last
topic here everything you said is
accurate that like no doubt
here's where I would like to at least
draw a line between your argument and my
argument
if you're going to compare
the riots or the everything that
happened during covid I think it's
unfair to compare them to what happened
in January 6 and I'll tell you why
compare those riots to the LA riots in
the 90s compare those riots to what
happened in Ferguson Missouri and
January 6th different situation compare
that to what we just saw happen in
Brazil compare that to what we just saw
in that coup attempt in Turkey five six
years ago with erdogan to me those are
the comparisons the the the well you did
this so you did this that to me is an
unfair this is my opinion okay and you
could have it yeah it's fine so and and
to me that's where I'm comparing it and
then and Pat because I know you want to
say what was the worst but but wait no
no but you can't say that let me you can
say that but that just because you said
doesn't make it right okay if you're
committing crime robbing store running
out with Louis Vuitton and all these
other bags and nobody's doing [__] to
you this guy's going to be in jail for
four years
that's a life-changing thing for this
individual he's going to be there for
four years how many of those guys got
away with it what are they doing to them
it's okay you're right on that but but
that but that's that's where you
you know like for example but when it
when crimes when when laws come out
let's just say we're starting a country
you and I okay and we're sitting there
saying let's hey guys uh Tom can we get
a board and let's get a paper and Pen
let's write the crimes on the board here
I'd rape how many years should rape get
I pedophile how many years should he get
all right selling drugs well weeds I
don't know well how about if you smoke
it that's fine how about to distribute
it what's the age hey how about cocaine
oh cocaine how about fentanyl all this
how about I'm selling Vicodin boom and
then we how about you kill somebody how
about you have a gun that's illegal
underage How about if a 27 year old is
caught with a 16 year old girl how if
you go through these things what are we
going to do we as leaders have to decide
which crime
is bigger okay which crime is bigger
okay stealing from property whatever
whatever
did you you caused billions of dollars
of damages to local businesses that are
creating jobs for black communities
black communities your own communities
BLM
and you're saying this is worse than
that really Based on data no there's
levels to Crime here one person one is
one too many over there 25 nearly 30 the
damage is not even close yeah there's
ways to measure and it's easy to
Gaslight it's easy to confuse it's easy
to say now how could you do that how
dare you you're a racist this this that
just because you call somebody racist
bigot whatever doesn't make your
argument stronger Ivory all it does is
gets others to be like oh that guy's
pretty emotional gets the people that
want to say he is you're right that's
true no it's not here's data folks you
effed up okay so who's the bigger damage
to America so don't sit here you know
saying this is the worst thing ever
since 9 11 Pearl Harbor which is not you
nothing you said that a lot of the
people who voted and said that yeah they
have to they have to realize the
comparison of those two with data Adam
catastrophic difference and Pat and what
my one of my points was the FBI and they
that's why they're showing the rayab's
guy if Adam the FBI was in there and had
ground agents pushing people to go in
because I saw the ray-ups guy broke down
the barrier with these people and made
them go if the module the same FBI that
[__] lied to us sorry about my
language about Russia and gave us a four
year a four year dude I lost friends I
lost Russian inclusion that same lying
Peter strzok Lisa Page FBI all these
corrupt pieces of garbage now they're on
the ground telling people push dog and
citing a riot pack you're going to jail
what how is Ray Epps still walking
around but the goddamn guy that's
wearing a ferret on his head that was
walking around is going to jail for four
years so if the FBI by the way FBI has
been dropping the ball forever and
they're involved doing [__] like this
good for them bro that's all I'm gonna
say that's it all right cool by the way
this was good the audience gets to say
Pat you have no clue what you're talking
about Vinnie relax or Adam you're full
of it or one of us is right and tell him
you know about Biz you get it okay if we
had to do one last story is there anyone
you really have a strong opinion on to
wrap up with
Megan Megan Kelly I'm sorry kellyanne
Conway single is that the one you want
to wrap up I love her Kelly I love you
do you want to do cotton with Garden do
you want to do Hannity with the Santas
do you want to do kellyanne Conway I
love you Kelly do you do you want to do
uh do you want to do uh Ford allows you
to lock your car if you don't make your
car payment they lock you out do you
want to do Tick Tock 60 minutes do you
want to do AOC against do you want to do
ramazwani rips Trump pick one of them
guys do you want to do Joe manchin blast
Biden pick a story
JJ Redick you wanna do JJ Redick do you
really really yeah are you serious sure
played a clip of JJ Redick and Everybody
Plays the clip of JJ ready
yes please go ahead and frame it I'm a
big NBA fan and uh I I anything NBA I I
I know a lot about let's just put it
that way friends are playing the NBA
games you're nice so uh I can go head to
toe with anybody that wants to talk
about NBA JJ Redick respect what the
hell of this guy just has done in his
career six four white boy out of Duke
all-time Duke leading scorer he uh he uh
took Kendrick Perkins and Stephen ate a
task about some of their thoughts on uh
biasedness of race uh in an MVP race can
you play this clip just make it make it
bigger so pause it first pause it first
okay he basically said who's the guy in
the right person
what'd he say Adam okay I don't know
let's see what he said but I know what
JJ said it is an honor to be on this
desk every day it really is but what
we've just witnessed is the problem with
this show where we create narratives
that do not exist in reality
the implication what you are implying
that the white voters that vote on NBA
are racist that are they favor white
people you just said that yes you did uh
yes you did I did yes you did that is
exactly what you implied that is exactly
what you applied secondly hold on hold
on I did not go I stated the facts I
stated the facts and you're not about to
sit up we all know what you implied the
other day we all know what you implied
hold on
the time
it's the facts it is
I think so basically Adam what Perkins
was saying is that they're it's it's
racist because it's it's a white guy
what is this the third time that he's
gonna win potentially they're talking
about the Colony Center for Denver
Nuggets and he was so he said yeah he
said something along the way in the top
three of the MVP race for the last three
years he wanted the last two years
running and he's averaging a triple
double this year yeah and essentially
the storyline is that white voters
prefer to vote for white MVPs uh over
black players black MVPs yeah so which
to me this is what Jay day is like JJ
Redick is basically like dude you're
ridiculous yeah because I mean even
you've said what Charles Barkley had to
say well please Charles Barkley went in
on Kendrick Perkins he says you suffer
from ESPN disease okay he says basically
you know what the hell you're talking
about you're all caught up in this you
know how many white MVPs there have been
in the last 30 years how many okay I
think I think Steve Nash won it twice
yeah jokic has now won it twice possibly
a third time and I think you got to go
back to [__] like the late 80s
okay since then Kevin Durant James
Harden LeBron uh KD Hardin Russell
Westbrook Giannis like the list goes on
and on so you know so what ten percent
of the time a white guy wins by the way
here's what people have to realize I
don't think people realize JJ Redick is
not a republican no JK Reddick is not a
Trump guy JJ's Reddick trashed Trump
just a few years ago talking about the
fact that waking up in the morning and
having breakfast you should wake up in
the morning have breakfast and criticize
Trump because that's the right thing to
do like JJ is not in this it looks like
well yeah you know he's a republican as
conservative he's this no all he's
saying is dude what the hell you doing
here man like and by the way if if uh
Kendrick Perkins wants to play the
racist game why is the NBA 70 black tell
me that why is the NBA 70 black why
while America is 13 black why is the NBA
70 black why does the NBA not have
enough whites while America is 22 23
Hispanic why isn't the NBA have a lot of
Jose's plane in it yeah
how come we don't have a Ricardo Aguilar
starting you know three guard for
freaking LA Clippers how come we don't
have that a lot that's racist right yeah
no his logic doesn't make any sense but
by the way
you have to realize that to me this is
my opinion this is my opinion
I go to ESPN to interview Stephen A
Smith yeah I've been looking forward to
interviewing Stephen A Smith
while we're going out there
he knows this is you know I've done
magic Kobe I've done a lot of different
things
ESPN comes up to me and they're like
look I just finished my interview with
Ray dalio and they said hey Patrick you
can't talk to him about politics ESPN's
asked me to cut the interview wow I said
what do you mean I'm just going to ask
what if he wants to talk about it even
if he does want to talk about it we'll
cut the interview so what are you
talking about yeah we're going to cut
the unit by the way if you look at the
set of my interview it you'll you'll
recognize the set go on YouTube Type in
uh Stephen A Smith with David you have
to see this they won't even let you talk
anything when you see our set you're
gonna know where this set is just look
at the set okay look at the set look at
the set click on it
I won't flag it
come on you know what set that is that's
the ESPN set go go go up or you've shown
both of us together like we're all
sitting that that's one go go right
pause right there yeah you know that set
yeah that's ESPN set there's ESPN guys
right on this side watching looking at
me saying you can't talk about that wow
and I'm about to go into it you can't
talk about that and Mario's Like Pat I
don't know what to do tomorrow is trying
to tell the guy let him ask the question
yeah he couldn't talk well anyway
Stephen A started talking about politics
I think Stephen A is uh in a tough place
and the tough place I think he's in
right now
he has sometimes in life when your
philosophies outgrow your peers
and you become clear about your
philosophies but you're still in a
community where your peers haven't
outgrown those philosophies of
victimhood all this other stuff
you you sit there privately and you have
to make a decision and the decision is
this man do I compromise all my friends
in the community I'm a part of to
say the truth stand up for what I now
believe in or do I keep these
relationships what do I do and I think a
lot of people believe it or not they
compromise and they don't want to lose
those relationships it's not an easy
place to be because you immediately
become lonely you immediately go from
getting 79
000 likes on Instagram posts to 13 000
likes yeah you immediately go from
getting you know 693 000 views on a
first a clip to 173 000 views and that's
a scary thought okay and ESPN right now
is getting killed uh clay Travis is
saying that these guys are going to go
out of business in no time I don't know
if that's going to happen I think
they're going to let go of a lot of
their lower level talent I think that
could possibly happen and if you think
about the companies that Disney is
willing to sell this is definitely one
of them yeah I was just gonna say who
owns ESPN they're willing to sell it so
actually they're shopping it yeah
exactly quietly that's how they divided
the companies into three different
categories so they can one by one sell
them okay so so exactly Bob iger's a
genius so they want to sell ESPN because
they've already seen a writing on the
wall but you know here's here's a crazy
question for you what's the opposite
side of ears what is the ESPN competitor
Sports I don't know about that like bars
never ever watch like I still till today
we will watch ESPN News
I don't know if I've watched any Fox
News sports back in the days I used to
when it was good I don't know if I've
watched a Fox News sport no it's one of
the few monoliths ESPN ESPN sports ESPN
sports
yeah ESPN is 10 National channels FYI
there's nothing like FYI FYI We're not
gonna do it but somebody ought to do it
it's a wide open space for somebody to
compete directly with ESPN I think
there's a Marketplace for it because for
the fact that JJ Reddick just made a
basic comment like that and that video
got 15 million views you know what it
tells you there's 15 million people that
would subscribe to your show if you had
a conservative you know competitor to
ESPN and there's not it's not out there
big time no company direct competitors
number one fox look how shitty it is
that nobody watches [__] Awards what
about ESPN the Ocho okay remember that
yeah yeah look at number two it's Star
Sports Star Sports keep going down the
list yeah who the hell is Star Sports
NBC okay four keep going keep going Sony
can I've never heard of it keep going
Euro sport okay
Neo sport now we're in another one
that's racist
just really fast I know we have to go
but what do you guys think uh uh
Kendrick perkins's intention was to say
something like that is it to get
eyeballs or to prove a point why do you
think he would say that when you know
it's fault when he knows it's false can
I tell you what please go ahead I'll
tell you what Charles Barkley had to say
because that's a credible Voice who
speaks his mind oh yeah you don't give a
[__] I don't know too many people that
hate Charles Barkley these days no you
don't give him yeah he tells like this
yeah so he says argument between Reddick
and Perkins apparently had been
simmering for over a week and Barkley
said that he was happy to see Reddick
challenged Perkins on his opinion quote
unquote this crossed the line JJ is the
only person to challenge perk last week
and I'm glad he did it because when I
heard it first I said man that's got to
be one of the stupidest things I had
ever heard Berkeley mentioned that race
was such a touchy subject when he
particularly bothered it's about this
argument he added that the MVP analysts
often don't analyze MVP races properly
because they don't consider it is
directly a strictly regular season award
um so essentially Barkley lavish praised
on jokic the MVP candidate again and
credit him for not chasing stats
something that he mentioned should be
accounted for the MVP steps this got
black white European gray yellow Asia I
don't give a [__] this guy jokic is an
MVP candidate and deserves all the
praise and the acknowledgment he has
received Markley would know he was in a
really heavy duty MVP race with Michael
Jordan and he won damn right 1992. Pat
look at that with the numbers Adam let's
go baby let's go yeah I mean it's it's
sort of laughable but uh but if you just
look at the stats Denver's number one in
the league jokic is the best player on
that team he's averaging a triple double
nobody's done that since Russell
Westbrook a black guy that won the uh
League yeah so I think I think this is
such a [__] argument I I if you now
if you want to talk about
front office is being racist in the NBA
that's another topic that we can that's
a whole nother segment oh my God you
want to finish it like that come on
the tape guy is racist the guy that's
wrapping your ankles front office the
general managers are talking about the
owners that's another level oh here we
go we're gonna miss you wow it's gonna
be great I'm gonna miss you guys as well
uh but I tell you this is it's so we'll
we'll talk to audiences there's a group
of pbd podcasters that'll say I only
want to see a home team I heard that you
guys talk Sheldon and there's those that
want to see the interviews and people
that come in but there's a different
story when we're sitting here shooting
the [__] having a home team type of
conversation I love it uh we have a lot
of fun doing that and uh we appreciate
you for doing the same gang again this
will be the last one we are finalizing
right now whether the event will be on
the sixth Thursday April or the 7th once
we finalize one of those two dates you
will get a text probably sometime this
week to buy tickets uh the last one sold
out within six hours if you do want to
be on our next live if you want to just
go on Twitter and play the clip to show
what the last one was like even if it's
just 10 seconds of it if you go on my
Twitter account just to show what it was
like uh uh the last pbd podcast we had a
great time sat there we did two hours of
podcast and we did 30 minutes of
questions with people going back and
forth we laughed we joked we met each
other we took pictures and then
afterwards those who were VIP came in
the back we had cigars together we
talked for another hour about politics
business family a bunch of different
things and a bunch of by the way what
was the craziest thing out of all the
people that showed up we asked the
question how many guys run businesses do
you remember the number 80 percent
80 if you want to be in a place to
network with other guys you can talk
politics business all of that and laugh
don't miss the next life that we're
having text the word podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 I'll put it here one more
time three one zero three four zero one
one three two text award podcast and we
will send the link it'll sell out
immediately and I think this next one
that we're doing we're gonna have a
special guest with us on this next
podcast because it falls on the weekend
of the UFC let's go
so we'll do the podcast we may have a
guest and then Friday Saturday I'm most
likely going to the fight on Saturday we
got a lot of crazy things going on but
having said that gang have a great week
we will do this again next week I know
it's a Wednesday have a great weekend I
know you got some stuff going on this
week I know you got some stuff going on
this week I know you got some stuff
going on this week so stay close to us
take care everybody bye-bye bye-bye
peace